e
e e
it being 9:00
I will call the finance division
2 meeting to start and we have the
Department of Education
today so begin with what we're going to
begin with please come forward introduce
yourselves good
morning for the record Frank GBL
Commissioner of Education
Tammy Valen cour CFO for the Department
um and so what I thought that we would
do is uh start out you have a PowerPoint
presentation some house spill 2 language
some staffing handout as well um as the
you know entire uh Governor's phase
budget packet um what I wanted to do was
just kind of give you an overview of the
budget for a moment through that
PowerPoint presentation I'll try to move
through that fairly quickly um and then
open it up for questions for myself and
then my whole team is available uh as
long as needed to answer any questions
that the committee might have um but I
thought it would be helpful to kind of
level set everybody through that
PowerPoint presentation so I would turn
your attention to this document right
now and uh the first thing that I'm
going to do is I'm going to introduce
you to the team of people here at the
Department of Education um so uh
Christine Brennan the Deputy
Commissioner was not able to be here she
had a a family emergency that she had to
tend to last night um and so was not
able to make it um but you can see that
uh uh that is the office of the Deputy
Commissioner and under that office you
have the um the Bureau of DDS uh
disability determination Services um
which is a something that we provide for
Social Security it's basically a service
provider to adjudicate disability claims
for the federal government it's fully
federally funded but an important thing
for you to context because you may not
think of that when you think about the
department of of Education um there are
about 80 individuals in that Bureau um
as well you have the uh vocation
Rehabilitation um The Bureau director
here is uh Rich Salah is sitting right
behind me the guy with the fair face um
and so he runs that Bureau Vocational uh
the Bureau of Vocational Rehabilitation
um we've also got the division of
Education analytics and resources and so
we've got Caitlyn Davis and Mark
manganella who many of you probably
already know because he does uh
education funding scenarios uh in his
sleep at this point in time um so you
can ask him many questions and also
Brian is here I'm looking behind me um
then we've got the division of learner
support which is uh Tammy or not Tammy
sorry I'm looking at my paper Melissa
sitting behind me over here um you know
all things education she's happy to um
to respond to that stuff as well we've
got the division of educator support and
higher education so Steve appelby is
right behind me as well and uh so he's
able to answer questions and then Tammy
has introduced herself who is our CFO um
I will say just a little bit of bragging
I do have the best leadership team um in
the entire state so they are sitting
behind me uh so my back is well covered
and they are and you are well covered as
well because they're able to answer many
questions on the next slide uh this is a
slide that actually um has some history
I first put it together when I got to
the department it is just in one page
gives you an overview as to what's going
on at the department Department of
Education um and uh it so it kind of
puts stuff in context I think a little
bit the way that this is organized um is
at the top it's like a p&l uh at the top
you've got all the funding sources that
we have coming into the Department of
Education uh we also carve out um
anecdotally the information that we have
relative to local education fun funding
uh District enrollment average cost per
pupil um and then the next sections that
we have in here and I think one of the
things that's really important for
people to understand is the department
uh like operates primarily as a flowr
organization we receive money and we
send money out to our school districts
is essentially what we do uh we try to
lift as little off of the top as we can
to administrate that process um but you
will see that so we've got um under
General funds you've got General funds
state aid uh you'll notice that there
are no residual funds but historically
there have been some funds in there um
and and some of those funds and you'll
see this throughout here so you've got
Dropout prevention Statewide special
education a Career Technical student
organizations um building Aid lease um
and I point out building Aid lease
because in uh the last budget or maybe
that was two budgets ago some of these
items were moved down out of the general
funds into the education trust fund so
as an example you'll see building a
lease is an item that is down I 1 2 3 4
five six seven lines up from the bottom
in the education trust fund at the
bottom so just keep an eye on that if
you don't see something up top just make
sure you didn't have it moved down below
the next is just general funds p through
so these are funds that the
legislature uh provides to the
department and our job is really just to
push those through into specific
programming um again some of those items
have moved down below most notably the
court order placements which is that
first item that you have there um and
I'm just going to briefly talk about
quot order placements so quot order
placements is basic basically uh uh if a
student is adjudicated by a judge to be
placed in a specific educational setting
um you know the state is responsible for
payment of the cost ass sets through
with that setting um and you'll you know
it's got $2 million but you need to
understand that that is uh a line item
for which we have warrant Authority so
that if it costs more than that I just
have to draw a warrant to be able to pay
those bills uh however many kids get uh
placed um and and we take care of that
um but you can see you've got you know
some scholarships uh you know the New
Hampshire Board of higher education we
may want to talk to about that at some
point in time but a variety of different
programs that you can see throughout
there and then you get down to really
the general fund salary and benefits and
operating um and so this is essentially
the Staffing uh costs and the um you
know the doit the Department of
administr Services costs that we pay
rent phones um associated with the the
team at the Department of Education and
we'll talk a little bit about Staffing
as we move on and then you get down into
the education trust fund where there is
a variety of um you know costs that are
associated with it some of this stuff
again has moved from below to above um
over the years as uh legislature has
sometimes moved stuff into the education
trust funds sometimes moved stuff out of
the education trust funds but kind of
has a transitory effect but it's all
kind of it's all kind of transparent
there for you to be able to take a look
at including um a number which is
generally highly um sought after which
is our district public school adequacy
number again Mark is here and Caitlyn
are here to address that um Charter
Schools EFA programs um that you'll be
able to see um and uh so these are a
variety of things that we kind of move
through the the one item that I will
point out at the second line up from the
bottom is the public school
infrastructure fund these are the safety
grants um that we have
received and in since
2018 and I think I'm pausing on this
because I think it's an important policy
thing for us since 2018 we have put uh
well north of $50 million into school
safety uh this is primarily around
hardening our assets so that uh you know
our children are safe and protected
includes and we work very closely with
Homeland Security on this but includes
things like Access Control Systems you
know making sure we got door locks that
we've got uh you know we use a certain
type of film on on ground level Windows
to make sure that those are protected um
every time that there is uh any kind of
a incident uh relative to safety of um
schools across the country um I
personally do a deep dive to figure out
what happened how did it happen uh do we
have the right controls and um safety
protocols in place to try and mitigate
that I'm not saying that you can
mitigate all stupid but we do what we
can to try and make sure but I I pause
on this as well to point out
that um I think that the funding
associated with this while it is not
insignificant I get that's a lot of
money um should not be a reactionary
funding line item so we have put uh $5
million at least uh into this every year
since uh more than that since I've been
the commissioner but um and and the
purpose is that we don't this should not
be reactive like we have a bad incidence
and so then we say oh my gosh we have to
harden our schools like I'm the the
opinion that we should just be like
making sure that we're taking and
upgrading our safety um all the time uh
to try and prevent something uh what I
would refer to as stupid from happening
so that just gives you kind of an
overall perspective of what a p&l might
look like for the Department on the next
commission can I we take questions
during your represent papich thank you
Mr chair and good morning thank you for
being here very quick question I don't
want to obviously we have a lot to go
through I was looking at Public School
infrastructure line you were talking
about and it seems to go from 1 million
a year two budgets ago to zero and then
to 5 mil do you have a bit of you know
color around that CU you were saying
you'd like it to be consistent and
obviously it's anything but so it
actually is quite consistent if you go
back it's just that what happens is some
of the funding sources where it comes
from don't show up in these in the
agency line item so for example last
year um I spent $10 million and I got it
from the yeah it's on it's it's was
onetime Appropriations we had some
Surplus and so you guys funded it out of
the surplus funds so we have
consistently since 2018 funded these
amounts uh sometimes the legislature and
us we get as creative as we can to make
sure we do it but we are always um you
know coming up with those funds for that
I guess before I leave that slide as
well then we have headcount although I
have a separate slide on headcount that
we'll be talking
about okay on the next slide um proposed
appro rations again this is provides you
a little bit more detail of the agency
phase versus the governor's phase on
some of the more important items that
you'll see um for example if you get the
district public school adequacy number
um bear in mind that we're doing our
initial calculation at the agency phase
well before we know what the fall
enrollment is going to be so we're just
kind of making some estimates as to what
might happen Governor's phase comes out
we have a little bit more information
even today we may have more information
so um that adjusts education Freedom
accounts similarly we're making adjust
and estimates uh you know before we have
enrollment numbers um and then the
governor's uh policies are reflected in
the governor's phase um special
education Aid again uh you know we had
the agency phase we do it at the time
that we have uh the information and as
you know it's been quite highly
publicized that we were $60 million
short in terms of our uh appropriation
for that and I guess I'll pause for a
moment at this as well and just explain
the process so essentially what's
happening is you have school districts
that are spending funds uh throughout
the year um and then at the end of the
year they send me a box of invoices and
we add those up so we had been
appropriated $34 million uh when I added
up the box of invoices in the fall I had
$50 million worth of uh invoices and so
we were $16 million short so we uh in
law we basically prate the amount that
we receive um and so the governor has
added that $16 million to that um we've
done some analysis since then uh to kind
of understand where um you know the
schools are with respect to that and and
what I would suggest is that you know we
don't have great internal controls
necessarily at the school level to flag
for the agency or for the state when
those items are over budget um you know
the districts themselves were about $60
million over budget on that line item
but that's just kind of information that
comes to light at the end of the year uh
the next thing that I will point out is
we started in the agency phase with four
proposed CTE Renovations uh for those of
you who are not familiar with the way
the CTE Renovations work is uh we have a
list it's kind of a Quee that school
districts get in um and it's a very uh
inadequate way of allocating Capital to
uh building projects in the state of New
Hampshire but it is one that has existed
for I think we're approaching 50 years
at this point in time um we have a study
commission that will be issuing a report
in May about a better way to allocate
Capital rather than just wait until uh
25 years has elapse and then you get to
try and build build again um and but
this year we did have four projects that
came forward um only two of those
projects has continued forward uh so we
had conal msic Jaffrey and Milford um we
only have Jaffrey and Milford who are
continuing forward in their uh
opportunity to try and do that part of
that is because uh to do a CTE rebuild
requires investment by the local
community and a vote by the local
community um to support you know the
state matches 75% and the Local District
comes up at
25% um and uh at this point in time none
of those districts has voted they will
be voting in the shortly here and we'll
see how those H those go we did have a
hearing with the public uh what was the
commission was it it wasn't Capital was
it capital capital yeah so we went to
Capital already and um you know they
said come back once you get a vote in
place right because we don't have the
local communities voted but two of those
projects are moving forward and you can
see as we go forward the numbers get
tuned up we're getting them very early
in the process I think I had to present
these like last April we were we were
initially submitting those um and as
they fine-tune their pencils um and and
they recognize the uh the fiscal you
know uh herdal and challenges sometimes
those numbers come down and you can see
that's the case here so um it was
interesting that uh Milford did not show
up in the governor's budget um we
believe that was an oversight uh we know
that they knew about it it was in our
budget we knew we submitted it to them
we even um while they were excuse me
putting their budget together uh we sent
them an email saying here's the updated
number but somehow that was there was an
oversight and it did not get included in
the governor's phas but it was always a
project and should you should not the
fact that it was not in the governor's
phase the school district did nothing
wrong all the communications were there
I think that was just an oversight on
the next slide um just to give you kind
of some perspective of enrollment in the
public school system
um if you want to know our Peak if we go
back to 2002 is when we peaked we had
230,000 students um so you can see we've
gone from 230 to two to 185 so uh you
know north of 47 uh, or 45,000 student
fewer students that we have at this
point in time in that system um and this
is a demographic trend that is has been
real for the pl past two and a half
decades but will continue into the
future there are um you know it's not
that difficult to see that uh you know
one of the things that I I sit as a
trustee for the University system of New
Hampshire and I have uh a traditional
thing that I uh present in my October
meeting I think it is we have like a
early fall meeting and I announced that
the class of 2035 started kindergarten
and plan accordingly right so we pretty
much know with this really narrow
standard deviation how many kids are
going to be available to go to the
postsecondary systems but it just gives
you some context in terms of where our
students
are papich thank you thank you Mr chair
a very quick question on this graph the
EFA students some of them do go to
public charter schools or non-public
schools is I'm assuming that this is not
double counting anybody in any way but
I'd like to understand which column does
a student go into when they are an EA
student that goes to a public charter so
first of all if a student is a public
charter student they would not be
eligible to receive an FAA
um but if a student goes to a non-public
school as an EFA student they are an EFA
student um the way that the law Works in
New Hampshire is that uh we have
compulsory education students between
the ages of six and 18 are required to
be enrolled in a an approved public educ
in approved education program at the
State of New Hampshire um those include
our Public Schools traditional in
Charter our non-public schools our home
education students as well as our um
education Freedom account
students on the next slide um what I
wanted to just point out is some funding
that came to the department through
surplus funds like so these are kind of
one-time funding and I point these out
because clearly these are not in my
budget um and in terms of the carry
forward items but it's something for you
to I mean so we spent the money we got
the money or we're spend we either spent
or we're spending the money because they
were one-time Appropriations but if you
go back to that Trend analysis on the
third slide where I gave you the
overview these are items that are one
time that would not be part of of that
um so for example student Clearing House
the legislature asked us to go out and
purchase a license for student Clearing
House to be able to track our students
that move into postsecondary um the
legislature provided $900,000 of funding
for mtssb work um primarily related to
RCA
135 um we received a million dollars to
develop Civics education curriculum uh
we did do that with Discovery Education
and continue on that work but the New
Hampshire Civics channel has been
published um we've got Computer Science
Education Program included $4 million um
to try and uh you know enhance the
number of computer science uh credential
Educators in our system uh we received
onetime funding for adult education of
500,000 um in many of the covid relief
programs the adult dead programs were
kind of like an afterthought at the
federal level and so they did not get as
much um you know support as for CO as
some of the other folks did and so this
was one time you know appropriation at
the legislature gave us for that work um
in terms of the education trust fund so
there you can see Public School
infrastructure fund was the $10 million
uh representative that you had mentioned
um we received a for CTE a tuition and
transportation Grant of $4 million um
and this was important to know because
we the goal was to try and provide
additional funds into uh CTE
particularly around tuition and
transportation um we did a $4 million we
did get an appropriation for $4 million
we did not put that as a formula Grant
out to the districts and it was very
specifically done that way uh the way we
receive about uh SE a little over $7
million of Perkins Federal money to be
used in our Career and Technical
education programming um that comes with
Ane maintenance of effort uh that if you
it's basically an all or nothing if you
decrease that by $1 like if you don't
you have to incre you have to maintain
or increase the spending each time if
you decrease you lose your whole Federal
grant um so we felt that it was
imprudent to uh the $4 million to the
ongoing funding knowing that that would
have made a per you couldn't do it with
surplus funds it would have been a
permanent funding commitment in order to
maintain our peras grants so we did it
as a competitive Grant and we've been
offering those competitive grants to the
districts um you know since we received
that funding um and and it is out there
right now even even so it's a non-aps
amount uh and I think we had about $1.6
million left uh or is it 1.6 was the
allocated do you remember about half of
it's been used yeah um kindergarten Aid
is to help those districts that are
expanding uh episode of treatment so
this is similar to court ordered
placements uh you know when the state
put the fast forward program in place
that allowed students or children or
really anybody to get kind of immediate
mental health supports if someone's
suffering then they send out kind of a
crisis team out there um sometimes that
results in someone being adjudicated
into an education program um because of
the the needs that they have there was
no fund in in order to pay the costs of
those and so there was kind of this
loophole between the Department of
Education and uh the Department of
Health and Human Services so uh we
created a law and and we so to to fund
these episodes of treatment such that uh
you know when someone gets adjudicated
we're able to use those funds to support
them um and then you can see as well uh
our CTE funding last year was done
through Surplus funding rather than
through the education trust fund or
through the capital budget um and those
two projects are underway and and uh you
know moving well in terms of being built
on the next slide you're going to see
our prioritized needs um and I'm going
to take these in reverse order if I got
any prioritized need the one I need the
most is that last item the state
administrator for assessment um and what
this is is so I have an individual who
is paid with federal funds um but that
individual needs to be working on some
of the state level efforts that you all
have passed particularly around the
Civics assessment um because they're
paid with federal funds they're not
permiss it's not permissible for them to
work on state requirements um and so I
need that allocation to be able to
administer the programs that you pass so
we got the law passed but then I need
somebody to basically administer that
and in particular this is going to be
around the Civics assessment and you'll
see we have some hb2 language there um
and we have been trying since uh 2018 to
get get a good grasp on this but it's
difficult to grab the information but
we've now built a portal for the
students to take the legislative requ
legislatively re ired um ins Civics
assessment um and it's the same assess
we buil it in the same assessment portal
that they use for the English language
arts for the science or for the
mathematics assessment so it' be very
easy for the districts to administer and
it's very easy for us to roll that
information up to provide you with
feedback in terms of how that is going
but I do need that Mo Money to be moved
over and then I'm going to talk about
the next two items which is the learning
platform um this is is uh vendor
specific uh which is always a little bit
nervous when you do something that's
vendor specific but this is for a
program called Discovery Education uh
during the the pandemic um we entered
into a contract we competitively bid and
we entered into a contract with a
company called Discovery Education to
provide highquality instructional
materials to our students um what we saw
is that some districts had high quality
instructional materials were doing a
great job other ones were sending home
you know kind of lousy manila envelopes
with worksheets in them and uh it didn't
really work that well so we did contract
with discovery education to make high
quality instructional materials
available to everyone in the state um
the what is exciting relative to that is
that every single School in New
Hampshire is using the platform right so
some sometimes I say sometimes like I
could offer gold bars and there may be
um some districts that are like nah
we're good here we don't have any place
to store the gold bars so we don't need
them but this is something that clearly
has met a need we've got well over a
million and a half engagements from uh
Educators throughout the state that are
working on that platform form so I I'm
impressed with the site my school
districts are impressed with the site
and it is essentially it is supporting
our local schools with high quality
instructional materials represa Murray
yeah thank you while we're on that I was
curious about it and we've heard about
this program before um I guess three
things I've reached out to several
school districts and teachers they've
never heard of it and so it's a little
hard for me to hear you say that
everybody's using it and loving it um I
also
some of the reviews you know I have to
say the reviews are wonderful in the
marketing but they're always going to be
wonderful in the marketing so I was
looking at other reviews of students of
teachers who have used it and said it
seemed great at first um but after
trying out with my students not so much
the lessons are very open-ended and rely
on self-motivated students um and it
goes on from there um there was another
review inconsistent quality of content
overwhelming amount of resources making
it difficult to navigate occasional
issue with um streaming um too
open-ended for a lot of their students
results in poor work life balance and so
um I found a fair number of reviews that
don't like it and as I and I also
reached out to RMC research I'm a large
research organization and ask them you
know their feelings about it and and ask
them to spread it into a wider you know
there are a whole lot of people who do
educational research and they came back
with a n you know with they're we're not
enthusiastic about it so I have
questions of its efficacy uh questions
that when I've reached out to school
districts they said we we don't even
know what that is so I'm happy to
respond to those and I think that those
are great questions and I appreciate you
bringing those up um so first of all I
can tell you I didn't see every teacher
but every school is using it um we do
what's interesting is that we have some
school leaders who have uh not
necessarily embraced and I'm thinking of
one District in particular School
leaders like no we're good here we don't
need this but I have teachers in those
schools in the very schools where I've
got school leaders are telling me not so
much I have teachers who are accessing
the program signed in and using those
resources in their classrooms today um
I'm not surprised that you could find
some reviews that are not that great
when you have over a million and a half
engagements anybody if I go to Google
and I look for uh you know any products
that's got a million and a half
engagements I'm going to find some
people are kind of like me I don't know
now and and if you think about the the
uh the nature of those um particular
reviews um you know it wasn't like this
is lousy it was kind of like oh it was a
little open-ended I didn't really like
it it didn't work as well for my student
population um you know so I I'm not I'm
not overly concerned because I can tell
you that overwhelmingly both in the
state of New Hampshire as well as I've
got colleagues uh you know across the
country who are using this platform who
also support educator satisfaction and
and a benefit associated with it um and
often times what's happening is in
particular those schools that have less
than robust curricular materials as you
know the curricular materials are the
responsibility of the local districts
and some districts are better fitted and
than others but those teachers that are
in the districts are finding that these
resources are what is uh is helpful for
them so I'm not surprised that out of a
million and a half engagements just in
the state of New Hampshire that's not or
anything that you would find some
individuals who are less than satisfied
but um the fact that I've got this and I
can guarantee that I have a deployed in
every single school there's at least one
teacher and I don't know of anybody
places just one but more than one who
are using the tool on a regular basis so
yeah um
okay I have a question um so none of
these on the governor's budget is that
accurate uh correct these were our
prioritized needs y um the next item is
State Testing um and so uh you may be
familiar with this or not but in uh so
under the the federal assessment regime
as well as then translates into the
state federal regime we assess students
in um you know math and English and
Science in grades 3 through eight and
once in high school and essentially what
that does is we so we're in we're
assessing them in grades three through
eight and then we kind of have this Gap
and we assess them kind of in you know
the March time frame as of in 11th grade
and we see how they are performing um
and so that is almost too late right
because at that point in time if a
student is not in good shape if a
student has fallen behind um we don't
have the opportunity necessary to catch
them up now the schools have a many um
you know uh formative type of assessment
tools that they're using in their uh in
their curricular materials uh and in
their their school systems on a regular
basis but what this is is would we we
would administer a PSAT in 10th Grade
right so you would either n9th or 10th
grade we would basically so we do the
sat in 11th grade this would be the they
called the P sat the preliminary sat um
and it would allow us to get a bead on
kids uh so you get to see more of a
straight line because otherwise I
basically I get to high school and I
have one data point in terms of your
performance for a student uh so
difficult to see kind of how the
students are making progress in that
system so so that's these are the
prioritized needs that we have have laid
out for
you um the next thing is I uh hb2
changes and so I've got a separate
handout for you relative to hp2 changes
um these are fairly granular so I will
I'm going to hit some of the highlights
associated with it um this includes both
uh policy things but mostly it's it's
comprised of technical changes it's a
document in your handout packet that
looks like
this sideways spreadsheet did you
provide that one as an as a PDF do you
know what the name of it was is it says
house bill to Department of
Education I have that but you have did
you send the PDF of that it's at it's in
the back of the presentation document so
the P pass the presentation keep
scrolling in the PDF if you're in the
PDF we've turned it into one PDF thank
you so then you'll see like item number
one is I we just talked about that this
is that 10th grade assessment for the PS
sat um item number two is uh the um
language that would modify the
efas uh in terms of eligibility for efas
a policy discussion that we could
probably have all day if you want to um
item number three is part of the
adequacy calculation this is some of the
stuff that's really just simplifying so
in statute right now basically I do the
adequacy calculation based on the Boi
the beginning of the year um and then in
April I do an update to that based on
changes that have taken place and it's
really meaningless exercise it um in the
sense that the school districts at that
point have already set their budgets it
doesn't really change all that much so
we're suggesting that we just have we we
do the assess we do the uh count at the
beginning of the year and we base our
adequacy on that number um you know
which just basically aligns to the
districts as well and and some of these
changes are possible now because we have
a Statewide student information system
um we didn't used to have one of those
we do now have one and we've gone live
with that and so we have better data so
the schools can have better data so you
can have better data in terms of
understanding what's going on um item
number four is just fixing some of the
uh the the language around the episodes
of treatment that we talked about um and
again that was a fairly substantive uh
change that took place um excuse me yeah
I don't number one you'd like the
changes to uh language if you will even
if you don't get the funding is that
what that note states there correct okay
thank you yeah so we really need to get
in other words like we can do the work
that we have but basically you know we
when we did episodes of treatment we
changed a whole bunch of laws both our
laws as well as HHS and we found there's
a reference that doesn't it's a missing
reference to the episodes of treatment
you know we're able to execute the law
but we're just clean these are cleanup
kinds of things
so um you know there's a technical
correction on the sped Aid uh you know
in terms of the we can use the actual
cost for that um another technical
correction um you know relative to the
calculations uh
you know lease Aid I'm trying to think
if there's anything kind of substantive
as opposed to um you know item number
nine is we talked about the assessment
for the Naturalization assessment that
people are you know students are
required to pass for going through high
school so we just want to make sure that
they go through that portal um to to
take care of their uh that
assessment um the uh item number 10 is
just clarifying the average daily
membership so we basically apply a
formula for vac in terms of how do we
allocate adequacy dollars to them we
just want to make sure and the law it's
the law is there but the law is a little
bit not it's a little bit open-ended
it's a little vague so we've been
applying a methodology for the past 20
years and we just think that let's just
tune up the law and make sure that the
law shows exactly what we're doing um
you know dispute resolution uh we
basically in special education are
required to do a a desal audit of that
but we're going we've now gone through
two uh LBA Audits and we'd like instead
of to do like state law requires me
every 10 years to do an audit of special
education since I've already been
through two in the last three years I
just assume let those count as the audit
for that if possible otherwise we'll uh
go out and contract it will cost us
$100,000 we'll have to go out and
contract with somebody to do that
otherwise but I don't know if it's
necessary um item number 12 is uh we've
got the uh computer science professional
development program that I had mentioned
that onetime funding that we had it was
non-aps funding uh we were approached by
the university system to try and offer
uh high school students the opportunity
to earn um High uh college credits while
they're in high school like we do with
the community college so now the
postsecondary system would also be
joining into that through CPS over at uh
the University of system of New
Hampshire system um and so this would
help to fund some of that
um uh 13 for I'm just
see uh so the uh item 14 is the these
are public school infrastructure fund
grants these are the security or the
safety grants uh the way that those work
right now is like we have uh we have a
public school infrastructure committee
it's made up of a it's a legislative
committee uh they meet periodically we
open up Grant windows we receive all
these Grant applications and then we
process those grants out this is an
opportunity to just expedite that
process to get those grants out um we
always have fully granted everything out
and we give schools a certain amount of
time to use those funds the funds that
don't get used we have a waiting list
list that the public school
infrastructure fund has has approved
that allows us like okay so say somebody
got approved for a $50,000 Grant they
spend $40,000 so I got $10,000 left I
just go to my next list on next item on
the ranking on my weight list and I
appropriate it this would allow us to
just directly make those Appropriations
to the weight listed um the the I the
schools on the weit list approved by the
public school infrastructure committee
so it's not like the Department's doing
this it's the public school
infrastructure is approved that so we
would bypass uh fiscal and just go um
you know be able to make those grants to
those
schools uh 15 was a uh cell phone policy
grant that was included in the
governor's budget so those that is some
House Bill 2 language um that we have
been
seeking represent Murray yeah thank you
uh just quickly to go back I think we'll
be going over this again at some point U
then where I assume
right um this special education dispute
resolution um you know the audit wasn't
so tell me what number was it um it's 11
11 um the audit report wasn't very
good and I would have questions about
having that reviewed every 10 years when
we have kind of a blistering review of
the situation now it seems that would
make some sense to have a more current
review given the problems that were
listed in the audit yeah so I mean if
you want to change the you know the
every 10 years to every five years
that's fine if you want to do that my
concern is is that we just finished that
and so then if this year I do that and I
have another ongoing audit as well so
then if I then have to do another one
you may not get the benefits that you're
seeking which is kind of a more periodic
look at this as opposed to cramming
everything into once and then we don't
look at it for again for 10 years so um
if you were to change the law that says
do it every five years something like
that that may make more sense yeah I
guess I would like to you know given
that their identified problems see
progress in addressing those problems
sooner rather than in 10 years so all of
those have been addressed you know that
we're required under these AUD to go to
fiscal committee and we've gone to
fiscal committee and closed out all of
those
issues
so okay then the last thing as a my
overview that I wanted to provide for
you is just kind of give you a sense as
to
positions um you have this
document in there and so what I have
done is I've gone through uh every
single position is open and or unfilled
um and I think that there are some
positions many of which are federally
funded some of which are uh generally
funded that we can eliminate at this
point in time um if I need to come back
to fiscal to get those positions
established again I can go ahead and do
that um many of those positions are uh
you know associated with um you know
Federal programs specifically uh some
Vocational Rehabilitation some DDS
positions um what's been really
interesting is that for DDS over the
years since I've been here we've added
positions to DDS almost everybody own
budget I think at this point right um
because the FED because as I tell people
it's because we did a good job and so
the feds are saying can you do can you
hire more people can you do more work um
what's interesting and and you'll see
that they we had initially asked for 10
additional DDS positions because Social
Security Administration asked us to do
those um we are asking that those now be
removed from our budget we don't want
those 10 positions only only because
there is so much it's so tentative
relative to whether or not Social
Security is going to ultimately fund
that or not they have not they asked us
in the last budget to fund a bunch of
positions and or to add a bunch of
positions and get ready for capacity but
they haven't fully funded those even so
until they fully meet their obligations
and fully fund the stuff they've given
us I don't see a need to add this to the
budget and knowing that I always always
have the opportunity to come to fiscal
and to resolve a problem that way um so
there's a number of positions there that
have uh that can be abolished but then
there a number of positions that we have
that are not filled that absolutely need
to be there in order to be able to
execute the mission um I think as many
of you know it's difficult to find uh
you know it's not that easy to recruit
people uh in the state and we do our
best um but a couple that I want to flag
for you that I want to ensure that I
cannot afford uh to lose these positions
so two are um you know 43257 and 4 3828
which are at the bottom um and this is
our uh Bureau of opportunities uh which
has oversight for programs our
non-public school programs um as well as
our home education programs so we've got
you know it's all the way second third
up from the bottom we've got 24,000
students in these programs and we have
you know like this is not like a
situation where we're you know missing
one out of a team of people we have one
person who administers these programs
that person took another job in the
department uh doing school building and
so that position is currently open and
so uh right now Caitlyn and I uh you
know meet the needs of that program um
and then as well the education Freedom
account uh administrator moved into
another role at Dees and so that
position is open as well um again an
important program an important program
to administer well um and so we would
ask again there's no other there's not
like there's a team of people there
there's one person administering that
program and so that went absolutely
needs to be administered um and the two
other that I'm going to flag for you in
at the top of the list 4 4967 and 449689
hire those individuals internally
because they um you know I think that
those they're they're important people
to managing the student data um but
we're getting good service from our
contractor so I'm not complaining about
that but I do we had these positions
previously and I think that we we
continue to to want them to be part of
that team but um you know if I can't
find them I can't find them I still got
to get the work done so we did a
contract for that um and so those with
that I will uh pause take any other
questions and then I know that uh my
team stands ready to answer any
questions that people might have thank
you uh representa Murray thank you I'm
just awfully curious at the bottom of
it's um 1319 who gets the
chauffeur yeah I said the same thing
right so that is directly um for the
commissioner to for me to be able to get
over here to the state house and back
I'm
kidding she's like
what no that is just the state
description of the position but
essentially it is in our blind Services
uh division so individ ual who are
visually impaired uh we are able to
support them sometimes to be able to get
them to doctor's appointments and and uh
stuff like that so
yeah so is that a person is that a phys
or is that something you would call Uber
uh so um Uber isn't always able to work
with somebody who's visually impaired um
so basically it is a position that we
have um and we um are able to staff and
and keep them busy um if we can't then
we won't you know staff it but it's
you'd be surprised how busy it can be
yeah a lot of doctor's appointments
represent D are those for students or
are those for your the staff no not for
the staff these are for our clients of
vocation Rehabilitation so vocation
Rehabilitation provides um you know job
counseling job coaching and supports to
individuals in the state of New
Hampshire between the ages of 14 and end
of life uh who have disabilities um and
so some of those individuals
uh you know have disabilities and are
not able to get to a job interview or
not able to get to a critical doctor's
appointment or something like that and
so we're able to support them in that
way did I do okay with that that's yeah
representative haen Phillips thank you
Mr chair thank you be for being with us
this morning Mr commissioner um I'm just
interested to hear more about um number
six on your house bill
two uh spread sheet the technical
correction to adequacy quote unquote
Factor
yeah so Caitlin do you want to
like Caitlyn can you come forward please
yeah sorry come to the
mic stay back there as long as I
can exactly when I leave they're like oh
my God so um that is literally left over
from Old Law so there used to be a
fiscal disparity Grant in the formula
and that was removed and combined in the
extraordinary needs Grant but the word
factor and that definition of factor was
just left in the definitions and it's
not no longer used throughout the
adequacy formula so we thought it' be
best to remove that
language just cleaning up the
law representative Murray thank you
again I imagine we'll be going through
this and we go through the line by line
but um just in general with regards to
the positions that to be abolished it
said by and large their Federal
positions and I noticed that there are a
lot of programs in the budget um that it
appears that a Federal grant is no
longer continued and I assume some of
these positions um have something to do
with the fact that that Grant doesn't
exist anymore I'm not sure which Grant
you're referring to well I mean there
are there's a where' my budget go so the
only one is we have the system of care
Grant but is there another one that
you're referring to there's we go
through it we can get to it I'm just
curious um with regards to the federal
positions um why aren't they needed any
more um and I appreciate that it is
federal in that but my just when I went
through the budget I'm wondering is
there money that's being left at the
federal table that should come to us
because I see an awful lot of grants
that are no longer being funded yeah so
the the federal is driven principally by
DDS and by VR positions and so what
you'll find in VR is again it's a bureau
that has about 80 positions in it um it
is a bureau that experiences turnover
the nature of the work is such that
there's turnover and essentially what
happens is you look at like what I did
is I looked at like the last dat I
posted these things and some of these
haven't been posted for a while and the
reason they haven't been posted for a
while is because we lost another
position so we just reposted that one
and so I guess what I would say is given
what we see as the movement through
there I have enough positions to satisfy
my ability to fill the people that I can
find um and so I think I I know that
this is a tough year and you guys are
looking for a position so I think I can
live without that and I'm not leaving
any grant money on the table right so
we've not lapsed any grants back
and again on the Social Security
Disability same kind of a thing it's uh
you know at least a cohort of those
employees are just they're processors
right they're just processing all day
long so you find turn over in there but
what happens is somebody turns over we
Poe that position we don't go back and
grab the old position and post it so I
have enough positions available to be
able to keep my Staffing at an
operational level so
y represent of hacka Philips yeah I'm
thank you Mr I'm curious about um the
move of putting the office of
Commissioners funding which used to be
derived from the general fund into the
education trust fund under the proposed
budget and I'm particularly concerned
given that the governor's budget already
drains the total of the education trust
fund by the end of 27 so I'm just
wondering why we're shuffling more
expenses into the education trust can
you point out what you're referring to
I'm not sure I understand what you're
referring to
um I think it's in
hb1 um the office of the commissioner
used to be funded by the general fund
but under the proposal it it would now
be funded through the education trust
fund I'm not sure that's correct so if
you can point that out I'm still I hope
that's right okay great yeah I'm
generally funded and my office is
generally
funded most days not every day huh I do
a good job I
generally section that proposes it is
section 18 of the of hb2 oh in the
budget to is also on
1075 um we take a look at that you want
to take a look I'm looking at it right
now Office of the commissioner is on
page 1073 of the budget then I'm looking
at 1075 where it says the general fund
um so the educ and then you see the line
you see the before that it's now I
understand you guys are asking hang on
this is easy
yeah the $5 million is for the public
school infrastructure
account which is on page
1072 so that is coming out of the
education trust fund is the public
school infrastructure those are those
security grants that we talked
about but I don't believe we have any of
you know
administrative stuff that's stuck in
there chairman could I comment yes sorry
so for many years the education trust
fund just funded
adequacy and when we left at the budget
the previous that's what we' done we
corrected it to just fund adequacy then
the Senate screwed it all up and and
they went from they doubled the amount
of money going from business taxes to
the education Trust fund which left us
with a huge Surplus which meant we had
money tied up we couldn't use anywhere
else it was poor planning it was a lousy
um mistake and I wasn't allowed to
discuss it in the committee of
conference because we didn't have one so
this year we're going to go back to just
funding adequacy and education trust
fund and it gives us more flexibility
for what we do with General funds which
all these other things that Frank
remembers were funded by General funds
so we're going to go back to that
pattern again so we have more
flexibility thank
you represent
D I'm brand new to this so forgive me if
I ask a stupid question there's no
stupid
questions in your budgets you have all
these positions that have been there
some of them have been there since long
time yeah each year are those funded and
if they are where did all of that money
go because they you weren't able to be
able to hire people yeah so generally
they are appropriated some of them are
funded many of them are not funded and
so there's no reason to carry them
forward they would only be funded if for
example somebody turned over and then I
had surplus funds then I would be able
to hire that position but what I find is
that I can turn over a certain number a
smaller number of positions and keep the
operation moving so some are funded many
are not funded but all are appropriated
great thank
you anybody else and then we're happy to
do the line by line and I've got a crack
team behind me who's just itching to get
up here and answer your
questions are you going to be
disappearing I wasn't yes exact unless
there's a need if the committee wants me
to stick around I can no it's fine I
just want to make sure that if anybody
has any further questions for the
commissioner this will be the time to
ask
them okay thank you very
much and if there are any follow-up
questions please feel free to give me a
call
right
you thank
you
cool thank you if you um are you
planning to uh you know kind of start
going through the lines uh and give us a
bit of color and maybe we'll we'll start
asking questions as needed or would you
rather do it in another way whatever you
whatever suits you we can go through it
line by line account by account if we
could and just obviously focus on what
matters and uh provide a little bit of
color so we understand any variance any
changes in there uh you know so we save
the inevitable questions okay thank you
so our budget starts on page 1071 of the
governor's phase
um in the very first account that we're
looking at that's the public school
infrastructure so you'll see that the
zeros and then we go up to the $5
million which is on the next page and
that is because as the commissioner
discussed we received $10 million from
23 surplus funds so that $10 million did
not show up in house bill one in this
document in front of you is just House
Bill one that's why you don't see the
$10 million and that $5 million is
education trust funds unless it gets
changed as representative wer was
discussing the next account is the
commissioner's account and if you look
down on page 1073 that is generally
funded as it always has
been yeah I just have a question because
I'm looking at hb2 and there is a um
question to amend RSA 198 col 39 Roman
numeral 1 to include funding the
Department of Education operating costs
within budgeted
Appropriations as subsection R so I'm
just
wondering uh if the commissioner's
office is currently funded with General
funds what is the purpose of the request
to change the education trust fund can I
just ask what page you're on in the BB2
um this was the old hb2 page 54 I don't
have the new one in front of me
yet what's the title how about that um
that is a modification of the current
law so the current law says so if
expenditures to administer programs
funded on the education trust fund P
pursuant to paragraph one exceeds
appropriate amounts the commissioner May
request of fiscal the general court um
additional funding and blah blah blah so
that is the existing law the governor's
office modified the existing law to what
is funded there however we do have the
authority to fund certain operation
operational costs at the Department of
Education through the education trust
fund right
now I'm Happ let you continue but can
you just tell me where we are in hb2 um
so me the section number
anything does it have a name or a
reference well yeah
so what what that is though is the
department does have the authority to go
to fiscal right now to ask for
additional cost associated with
administering programs so not additional
costs associated with their program so
we wouldn't if we needed additional
money for say building Aid we couldn't
go to fiscal to do that however we if we
needed um additional funds to administer
the building aid program we could go to
fiscal to ask that that eliminates that
down essentially and takes the
Department's Authority away for us to go
fiscal it's it's it's restricting the
Department's Authority so for those
watching at home I believe it's section
120 on page 54 of hb2 was
introduced plus Mr landan corrects
me okay Kaitlin I'm so sorry it's
probably the fact that I've been up
since 4 a.m could you say that one more
time so yeah so RSA
19839 currently and of course I don't
have HB two proposals in front of me I
have the current law but um the current
law allows the Department of Education
to go to fiscal to ask for additional
funds to administer the education trust
fund um so this is one of those things
that over the years uh the legislature
has added additional programs to the
education trust fund without granting
the department the administrative um
ability to or the without granting the
department additional funds to
administer those programs and so two
years ago or two budget Cycles ago the
department asked the legislature to give
us the authority to ask you if you are
putting a new fund or a new program or
expanding a new program if we could have
the authority to request additional
funds to operate that program um and it
was determined that we could come to
fiscal to ask for that Authority that's
what's in current law so let me give you
a good example of this so we have the
charter school program the charter
school program is administered um or
charter school funding is in the
education trust fund we may need for
example an addition additional person to
oversee charter school funding we had
actually had some internal conversations
even about requesting an additional
position um to provide additional fiscal
oversight relative to Charter Schools
this was a conversation that came up
last spring when we had two charter
schools closed in the middle of the year
and and there was thoughts about
additional oversight what the Department
of Education could do right now in
current law is we could request an
additional position or funding from FIS
SCH to do that additional oversight um
and use education trust fund dollars to
do that because the charter school
funding program itself is in the
education trust fund this modification
here takes that Authority away the
department did not request that um in
hb2 I was surprised when I saw an hb2 um
but that that removes that Authority
from the
Department can I ask a followup yeah
absolutely
um so um maybe I'm
misunderstanding um so apologize I
apologize if that's the case um we know
that there are like three open warrants
currently in the trust funds so like
building Aid I or no I'm so sorry um
Charters um quarter Replacements there's
another one I'm sorry I'm blanking
charter schools efas and qu plac yeah so
are you saying that if we agree to this
change that it would limit the
Department's authority to to go to
fiscal to ask for that no so the
department right now so the um the
language that I spoke of that's in the
current law the department has to go to
fiscal to ask for the additional funds
for that for the ones that we have the
warrant language on we don't need to go
to fiscal we just write basically a
letter to the treasurer's office asking
them to appr um increase appropriation
um to pay those lines the warrant
Authority that we have is specific in
the programs that are established so if
look at how adequacy is established it
then um talks about the formula and then
it says the department has warrant
Authority same with education Freedom
accounts it talks about the formula and
all the program and then it has um the
warrant Authority um so there is not any
warrant Authority on um say building Aid
so we couldn't ask for additional
Authority for that um for that building
Aid the department done then on top of
all of the programs has operational
costs associated with operating those
programs we have a building Aid
administrator we have a charter school
administrator right now the current law
allows us if you know if needed if the
department felt needed we could go to
fiscal to ask for those additional
Appropriations to expand our operating
costs associated with those programs and
so hb2 as the governor's office has
proposed removes the Department's
ability to do
that can I are you okay or so I want to
follow up with what she was just asking
so it sounds like you don't have this in
front of you the hb2 because I'm curious
where in this section it's removing that
Authority that you're talking about um
so it uh there's a bunch of things in
here right so what it does it's um it's
the education trust fund um section do
you have it printed I have what you gave
me but I don't I do not have it give me
my I'll computer
oh I don't even see anything about the
education trust
fund you're talk represent hack and
Phillips
so you're talking about a a section that
has the title adequate education
education trust fund amend RSA 198 colum
39 comma blah blah blah do you see
anything in there about the education
trust fund that's what I'm trying to
understand what you what she's talking
about give me it it says page 55 um like
says page 55 I don't know that it's PDF
page
55 page 55
yeah read what you're reading and in
it's um letter r it says to fund the
Department's operation costs within
budgeted Appropriations okay which
doesn't match mention education trust
fund just to be clear um so this section
is specifically so it's um on page 54
the line before um row 26 so this is the
RSA that establishes the education trust
fund it's RSA 1
9839 okay so that that line that says to
fund Department of Education operating
costs within budgeted Appropriations is
taking taking away an authority from you
is that what I'm to understand um we
believed it to do that we haven't had
any discussions relative we saw in this
too and we haven't had any additional
discussions of you know what the
intention of that was but we felt that
that was what the um purpose of that was
and what Authority is it taking away
just the authority that we currently
have under RSA 18938
Roman numeral
3 but in in plain language what
Authority um if required expenditure if
required expenditures to administer
programs funded by the education trust
fund pursuant to paragraph 1 exceeds
amount appropriated the commissioner of
Education May request fiscal May request
the fiscal Committee of the general
court authorize additional funding
amounts requested under this paragraph
shall be charged to the education trust
fund does everybody else understand that
how that's are moving Authority yeah I
I'm very concerned about that
um
the well I think the impact would be
that if if in fact as the governor's
budget proposed that
the education trust fund was emptied by
the end of the 27th bium that we would
not be able to go and ask for the
education trust fund to be backfilled is
that correct
Mickey can you provide any context can I
take a try maybe that might help so I
don't I don't have the house bill to in
front of me but that statute that's
being amended is the permissible usage
under statute of using education trust
funds yeah so what House Bill 2 adds
this is just my interpretation I haven't
talked to the department yet about this
it just adds a couple permissible usage
including to fund education operating
costs within budget Appropriations so
they would still be a limit to Authority
granted to the Department of how much
the education trust fund they could use
for operating but this just statutorily
makes it compliant as a possible use so
when I when I look at like for instance
accounting unit
2196 ETF
Administration on page 1171 of their
operating budget so from this account
they have a position budgeted so to me
this house bill two language would make
it so that's permissible
do you agree that is that's correct I
that Roman three so so say again
reference the hb1 again so in house bill
one accounting unit 2196 on page
1171 is relative and the department can
speak a little bit more about what this
position does but there is some
operating costs relative to uh ETF here
so to me this house bill two section
that adds an allowable use of the ETF
for operating costs I view it to apply
to perhap perhaps making this compliant
um relative to the Department's
authority to come to fiscal to ask for
additional funds if it exceeds their
budget amount that's Roman three which
is not changed by this house bill too um
there could be I think what the
department is interpreting that any
operating cost would be bound by
budgeted Appropriations therefore they
couldn't come to fiscal uh I can tell
you that based on what representative
wer has has talked about plus whatever
this committee does we are going to
completely probably rewrite this statute
so what's in House Bill 2 now uh you can
take it as you know we're still trying
to work through it but ultimately we
will probably have an amendment in this
division to align with how you fund the
Department of
Education so right now what I'm hearing
that this is more additive it's not more
restrictive it's adding additional
authority to go to well the authority to
go to fiscal still exists I believe this
I think the intent was trying to just
add more permissible usage you know the
cell phone uh policy for instance and
then adding anything else for Department
operating costs but within budgeted
Appropriations making it clear like it's
still going to be bound by what you
appropriate but as an allowable use but
like I said we will completely revisit
and probably re rewrite this amendment
and and over write it with something
from this division in the coming days or
weeks thank
you so I kind of left the room there to
use the restroom what did we jump into
doing hb2 is that where we are
no no that's okay I just okay so we're
actually one page in we went okay
perfect you are out for one minute I
mean I thought I was quick but
apparently not quick
enough so I before we get started here
on this just to give you a heads up in
terms of what I need um as we move
through this wake up um I don't I'm not
really looking at the PDF I'm actually
looking at your budget so when you make
it when you make references to PDF page
numbers or actual page numbers whatever
you want to do over there would you also
reference account numbers because that's
where I'm searching for over here
sure so we had left off on discussing
account 6001 which is the
Commissioners that is generally
funded um and I just I'll go through it
unless you have questions and stop me um
the next account is our
6165 the unemployment compensation that
is you know mandatory that we fund that
along with the unemployment compensation
or I said that already what's the next
one the workers compensation
8062 that ends the commissioner's
Division and as you know it is funded
generally funded as well as the
education trust fund
the next is the office of the Deputy
Commissioner our first account is human
resources
1207 that funds our human resources
staff next one is 20 2022 our governance
unit I think I'm okay and you can still
also reference the page numbers in one
for everybody else okay that's on 10
page
1076 repr Murray yeah can you just
explain a little bit there um it's one
position left uh so it's you went from
three positions down to
two um and I see the Personnel line
going down in benefits but you've have
you hired it looks like you've hired
a temp person or temp appointee on 50
the line 50 can you just speak to the
shuffling around so we unfunded a
full-time position and moved the
available funds into the class 50 so
that we could hire an additional
investigator okay I have a f um Mr chair
uh I'm looking at
line I guess uh 102 contracts for
program services that um expenditure is
grown exponentially could you give us a
little explanation of what's going on
there I
can so we've had um
expenses rise over the last few years we
have our Brody law contract that we need
to do for the title 9ine
requirements we have ever law which is
our right to no software that software
are we need for redaction and that seems
to be increasing we started out with
like a $50,000 contract we're up to
$80,000 and the more right to knows that
we get the more that it expands that
contract expands so that's why we the
price or the appropriation is
increasing the um line 235 transcription
Services has also gone up is that also
related to right to know or is that
something
else transcription so that is 15,000 for
25 and we're asking for 10,000 so this
actually gone down by I was looking at
the total I apologize
sure on page
1077 we've gone to the preschool
development Grant um that has gone down
to zero that was a grant that we
received from
usnh
yes pass
through we have on 1078 we have
accounting unit 3910 Senate youth
program that is funding that we receive
through
donations on 1079 we have teacher of the
year
4132 and that is our teacher of the year
program where
we do our promotion of the
teachers yes
page
1080 is our 4275 that's our doit
expenses General funds it is increased
slightly 6002 is our business
management
account am I going too fast too slow is
this okay okay
okay on 1081 we move to the deputy
commissioner's account
60003 and then 10 page 1082 our in
Statewide agency indirect cost plan
64 those are funds that we collect from
our federal grants and pay the swi out
to admin services
so when that references uh agency
indirect cost recoveries what for the
funding source 00c what does that
referred to that is how we collect so
admin Services requires that we have
this in one accounting unit so we assess
an indirect cost rate to all of our
federal programs we collect those funds
from those accounting units and dump
them into this accounting unit so then
we pay admin services from this one
accounting unit thank you
um 6006 is the teacher competence fund
the this is a
um trust fund that is held down in
Treasury and Page
1084 we have our printing revolving fund
which is accounting unit 6530 this is
how we pay for all of our um
uh copers in the
office and then on that same page is
accounting unit 7007 this is our fiscal
management unit that oversees the
finances of all of our federal
grants and that completes the office of
the commissioner or Deputy Commissioner
I'm
sorry our next division is education
analytics and resources so Caitlyn if
you want to come up if they have any
specific questions um this is Caitlyn's
account it's made up of federal funds
education trust funds or I don't know if
they are in that um General
funds account number
sorry you want to do it that way or you
want me to get the
okay so our first account on page 108
well 1086 is 2450 Charter School startup
grant that is a federal
program the next account is on page 1087
or it starts is accounting unit 3041
education analytics and resources and it
goes to the next page 1088
on page 1089 we have our compliance
account
3042 that oversees Federal compliance of
all of our
programs on page 1090 one moment oh I'm
sorry muray has a question coming
I was keeping up for a while sorry um on
1089 um get my thing line
it it's coming it was General funds and
then there's a big increase in it and
now it's from Interra agency transfers
so the purpose of this fund is um or
sorry this this accounting unit is
there's three staff that oversee our
compliance with 2 CFR which is uh a
federal General guidance over all
federal grants we have a team of three
people that monitor uh School District's
compliance with that Rel and also um
assist the department with its own
internal compliance um of to CFR
specifically um we spend a lot of time
working with KPMG and our U various
Auditors US Department of Education was
here auditing us last week actually um
and so uh that's where those staff are
paid um in the past what we had done um
we just this is really a a change in
accounting methodology um but we what we
done had done was budget them in general
funds and then Bild them back to federal
funds um and so what we have because
there's not enough federal funds to
support all of the needs of that um of
those programs unfortunately of the of
the compliance requirements so we've
just really done an accounting change so
instead of billing it back through class
10 now you'll see um throughout the
agency it's going to be built back
through class 29 which which is inter
agency transfers and so the general
funds rather than being budgeted in this
account are now going to be budgeted
with in the various different accounts
that they support which we felt was more
transparent on page 1090 we have
accounting unit 3044 ncees
survey can I ask what ncees survey um
yeah National Center for Education
statistics um it's a a survey that we
participate in every year and they give
us a supplemental amount of uh funds to
cover the training of the C of the
sending the staff to DC to participate
um in essentially the training and the
results of that that survey
thanks then on page 1091 we have our
education opportunities accounting unit
on page 1092 we have our educational
statistics I mean my apies I'm
particularly interested uh this may not
be the correct accounting unit but I'm
particularly interested in uh where
refunds go um
or I'm particularly I'm thinking about
the audit this past summer of the
educational Freedom accounts um by our
administrator that found about 20% of
the audit showed inappropriate
um um issuance of the efas and at some
point some of that money was supposed to
come back to us and I'm just wondering
has that money come back and uh where
where would we see that so that those
funds are um there's this individual
accounting unit that education Freedom
accounts are in in this budget it's
actually I think like the very last page
um so depending on how long we go today
we'll get to that um but it previously
it was in was an accounting unit called
3054 and it was the education trust fund
as a whole and it had individual classes
one was a building aid class was an
adequacy class one was an EFA class so
that would have been deposited directly
back in that class um same with that
reconciliation that um Kei Baker when
she was here on Friday talked about um
that when she talked about having that
liability on her um financial statements
that when that's refunded we we get the
check back from her and we deposit it
directly in that
line uh you said previously is that
supposed to change in the future so um
one of the things you'll see uh that the
department did um under the suggestion
of administrative Services is rather
than having one accounting unit with all
of the um individual EFA or sorry ETF
programs in it um admin Services
requested that we have a specific
accounting unit for each program within
and a line within each one so it clearly
shows whether it's a grant or a contract
or Personnel expenditures or or whatnot
so
okay on page 1092 the educational
statistics account
3047 and then moving on to page
1093 is the school facilities
3058 accounting
unit page 1095 four we have a federal
assessment accounting unit
3059 repres Murray thank you um getting
down there with 1095 so there are seven
positions lost are these some of the
positions that are listed in the um the
the page that edelblute submitted to us
no these are positions so um what we
have had done in the past is we has hous
affair number of positions in this
accounting unit that were actually data
support positions and then they were
build back to the appropriate program
that they oversee and so they've now
been moved to the appropriate accounting
unit and as they support Federal
assessment um Federal the federal
assessment Grant which this is the one
we're talking about here will pay for it
through a time and effort but really
they are in the the data group as a
whole now so we can really have a a
stronger understanding of where our data
positions actually
are on page 1095 we go down to our New
Hampshire building
authority there were no funds asked for
that this year and then accounting unit
33000 on that same page is our youth
risk behavior survey those were federal
funds and that Grant is no longer with
us on page
1096 we have accounting unit 3471 which
is our school Finance
and on page
1097 we have national forest and land
3472 accounting unit those are federal
funds those funds are pass through funds
to there's a formula that is given to
us um so they are funds that are earned
Leed from um Forest activities in
National
lands exactly so it goes so those those
funds go to the school districts um
which have the national forest with them
I believe there's may be some in Grafton
and Carol as
well on page 1098 we have accounting
unit 6715 the slds finance Grant
student longitudal Data
Systems longitudinal Data
Systems we have to shorten accounting
unit titles because there's only a 30
character limit that we are allowed and
that 30 characters includes spaces
so um
representative heck Phillips I'm looking
at line uh 102 contracts for program
Services we're looking out a pretty big
jump there could you describe what's
happening yes so this is a um a fouryear
grant um and fiscal year 24 real
actually fiscal year 25 is the first
year that we received the Federal Grant
and then we received additional funds
through the next year so we're
anticipating this grant going for three
more years um and it is to uh really
realign our Data Systems specifically
around school Finance so we're we're in
the process right now we have an RFP I
should actually say this this is a
public meeting we have an RFP out right
now um for uh an accounting firm to
hopefully help the Department of
Education uh review and change its chart
of accounts that school districts use
for when submitting all financial
reporting the current system has been
placed since 1999 and we're really
hoping to have some modifications to
that um so there's my commercial for the
day um uh but um this is work that's
needed in New Hampshire regardless and
unfortunately we're we are able to
leverage federal funds to do that work
um hopefully those funds continue to
flow we're not sure what's going to
happen with the the federal government
but um as of right now we're planning on
using Grant funds for that
initiative on page 1099 we have our
accounting unit 7064 State assessment
and
accountability um because we joined an
additional um additional membership so
before we only had the state federal um
sorry the state assessment membership
and we joined the state accountability
membership as
well represent Murray thank you um on
612 where did State Testing get moved to
that was moved to its own line within
the um education trust fund as
well so it has its own accounting unit
um we'll see at the the end of the book
on page 1100 accounting unit 7128 is
State longitudinal Data
Systems and Page 1101 is our advanced
placement fee for
7374 our nape assessment is on the same
page accounting unit at
7375 the national National assessment
for Education
progress it would be a long chart
we we have improved on
nape on page 1103 we have oh we
end our educational analytics and
resources accounting
division our next is our higher ed
educational support and higher ed which
is Steve applebe is a division director
so first accounting unit on page 1103 is
1859 Career School
licensing and that
is our next is on 11:04 is our
scholarship for Orphans of veterans
accounting unit
1864 on page 1105 we have our New
England Board of higher red that's
accounting unit
1865 the next page 1106 we have our
higher ed transcript administrative fees
which is accounting unit 6777
on page 1107 we have higher ed education
commission accounting unit
8679 page 1108 we have accounting unit
908 which is our education credentialing
account and what is the agency income
there
what does that refer to agency income
that's teacher
credentials anything
else yeah um good morning Steve Appleby
director educator support and higher
education uh our educator credentialing
Bureau uh licenses all K to2 public
Educators in our state as directed by
the State Board of Education so those
are the licensing fees that the
Educators pay
yes thank you
on page 1110 we have our Harriet
Huntress fund accounting unit
9012 and then there's the Hattie Livy
fund
9014 Murray thank you in the
organization notes it talks about you
know give an outright to assist worthy
pupils in the state normal schools is
that something that needs to be changed
do we even refer to normal schools
anymore um I didn't have normal schools
growing up my mom did so thank you yeah
normal schools referred to Plymouth and
Keen um but is this the right language
now I mean I'm I'm sure there are people
who don't even know what a normal school
is now agreed agreed I would note um
that would be probably a legal question
because in the um these individuals left
money to the state and as part of that
trust document that's how they State
these schools
on page
1111 oh we're done higher
red there you go thank
you well
done our next division is learner
support I believe and that's with
Melissa Wright as the division
director white Melissa white sorry
our first accounting unit that was 1074
that a grant that was a grant is no
longer with us so we'll move on to
1573 which is the same Grant but
2.0 uh office of student and emotional
Wellness
promising Futures 2.0 Governor's
commission
fund on page
1113 we have 2171 our student wellness D
State r m down the next page can you
speak to the cut in that program
it's out of the general fund
yeah we were required to make general
fund cuts and in that program you'll see
that the contracts line went
down with that program we had initially
had put in uh for Contract Services in
order to have an evaluation done a
comprehensive evaluation of the
Statewide implementation of the
mtssb her behavior and supports and it
was more important to prioritize the
staff that are actually going out
working with the schools on the
implementation so we did cut the the
contract and for the evaluation and
hopefully we'll be able to use U
competitive Grant funds and apply for
those in order to do that work that
evaluation on page
1114 we have the school nutrition
equipment fund 2172 those are federal FS
that's a Federal
grant
11:15 we were looking to consolidate
chose not to do that so those funds that
were in there for 25 have been dispersed
back to the federal grants from which
they were intended to come
from so on the same page we have
accounting unit 2322 which is our school
nutrition
program or part of it we have many of
those coming
up page
1116 you added a person there I'm sorry
you added a person there in the
nutrition
program I I think what they've done is
that we're trying to align our accounts
with the federal reporting requirements
and so if there's a person there that
person has come from a prior or a
different School nutrition
account every time we think that we have
our accounts aligned to how we can
report they change the
reports it it's
challenging thank you you're
welcome um on a page
1116 2370 School climate transport that
that Grant went
away ended I should say the same with
2380 and so next we're at 252 digital
digital literacy for educators on page
118 and where is this agency income
coming from this agency
income that was from a competitive grant
that was uh given to the Department of
education many years ago for uh
improvements in digital literacy and so
we've just maintained those funds to be
able to go out and do specific uh Grant
work website development that type of
thing um to kind of help those schools
but the the grant itself was um provided
to us years ago and we've just kind of
maintained that until the funds run out
a f a Federal grant no this was actually
a competitive private Grant
what does that
mean so my understanding it's similar to
um I was thinking of the nonprofit here
in New Hampshire that that does a lot of
the grants where they um give out grants
for different things and I have to say
this is before I um came to the
Department of Education so I'm a little
bit it's a little foggy in there New
Hampshire charitable trust that's the
one um provided that for this work thank
you
on page 1119 we have instructional
support accounting unit
253 and Page 1120 we have our special
education accounting unit
2504 so is that all of the federal funds
that come related to special education
or the vast majority of them I that's a
better way to put it correct we receive
the 2504 is the idea funds that are for
K to2 and then we have 2505 which is
going to be the preschool idea
funds which should be which is on page
11:21
starts 1121 and 11:22
page 1123 is our state professional
development is
2506 page 1124 is our project to wear
grant that we no longer
have can you specify did it end or ended
yes on page 1125 is accounting unit 2509
that's our Title One
funds on page 1126 is accounting unit
2510 that's our title two
funds then we'll move to page 1128
accounting unit 2511 is our title 4 B
funds representative thank you Mr chair
quick question on U page 1126 U account
2509 obviously I'm not unhappy about a
large increase in federal grants but I
was wondering if you could give me an
idea of how come we are so
lucky the Federal grant
lines have been increasing significant
and it would be nice to understand why
okay um these grants are 27mon grants so
they allow for carry forward so we have
a large carry forward available to us so
we need to increase our appropriation to
be able to spend those funds that's when
I was getting used to the second year
carryover in the budget now there is the
multi- budget carryover thank you you're
welcome
on page 1129 we have TW accounting unit
2512 that's our Title 1 C funds migrant
education can you speak to why that's
dropped so
much thank you for the questions so we
have seen a significant decrease in the
number of students that qualify for the
migrant education program so that
identification has gone down
um we tend to find here in New Hampshire
there aren a lot of uh because it's
agricultural there's very strict uh
guidelines for how you can qualify for
those funds and so those students tend
um to be very little compared to like
Vermont they have a much larger
population than we do so we go out we do
the work of identifying the students and
then we uh our funding is based on the
number of students that are
identified on page 11:30 we have 2513
that some migrant education Consortium
Grant and that Grant was a competitive
grant that went along with that other
Grant so that we could uh increase our
identification efforts and and do an
analysis and that's where we were able
to determine
that those
students the numbers have
decreased on page
1131 accounting unit at
2515 is our homeless education
grant I read Dy could you just explain
what that Grant is all about I know it
says homeless but I mean thank you for
the question so the mckin vento grant is
specifically part of title one so
there's a a component that that they
carve out specifically targeting
students that um identify as homeless
and so we can provide uh our Educators
in the state some training on how to
identify and support those students in
addition they do get an allocation so
that schools identify those students
then there's an allocation that goes
along with them to help support those
students on page 1132 accounting unit
2516 is our title three English learners
I don't Mr I don't want to uh make us go
backwards too far but I think it'd be
helpful for the committee can you go
back to page 1120 so the uh Ida special
ed 24 uh 2504 accounting unit that's
where there's a big uh bulk of uh the
federal fund or the federal positions
that the commissioner suggested could be
abolished I don't know if you want to
speak to those while we're kind of going
through the accounting units and where
the abolished positions
are there were like eight yes
so do you want to speak to that no there
were udl there were several
yeah which account specifically of those
are you talking about 25 it's the top
one two three four five six seven eight
top nine positions um on this
document I just became aware of it just
now okay
so several of those positions are
Universal Design learning implementation
specialist those were created we haven't
been able to fill them which I again he
has said he is eliminating some
positions that we are having difficulty
filling if we need them we can always go
back to fiscal to request them as
temporary full-time
positions but yeah I think there's like
nine positions here
so it's because it's
I've on 11:21 it shows 30 out of 30
there's not a change there so those
numbers are not reflected how does how
do I find these Cuts here when it's I
don't see it on this page it says 30 out
of you know it still says 30 people you
won't because this is the Govern we're
looking at the governor's recommended
budget this document is the commissioner
is providing to division two as
an option for reducing our divis
department
count so that it's not shown here but it
is from this group of 30 correct thank
you so going back to page
1133 we have our accounting unit 2518
which is i title 4
a and on page
1134 we have accounting unit 2519 which
is our title 4
B page
1135 we have accounting unit 25 523
which is our Title One neglected inter
delinquent and on that same page we have
accouny unit 2526 which is our school n
nutrition school
programs this
is the funds that go out for food
nutrition to the schools
represent
D again I'm new so I'm trying to learn
what all of these things do the school
nutrition is that the three is that
three meals a day that you're supplying
to all of the students is that what this
is uh no this is for the free and
reduced um lunch and breakfast program
that we provide for students and it's on
a reimbursement basis and so students
that participate um they have available
to them the if they have a breakfast
program breakfast and schools that are
operating it and then a lunch if they're
operating the school nutrition program
if they're not if a school doesn't um
operate the school nutrition program
then they they do not have these get
access to these funds and do we have
many student schools that don't uh we do
we do okay let see thank
you on page
1137 School nutrition FF
BP fresh fruits fresh fruits and
vegetables
program accounting unit
2527 the next page is 1138 and the
another school nutrition child and adult
food
program and the next accounting unit is
2529 which is the school nutrition
summer food on page
1139 page 1140 is our assessment
professional development accounting unit
2534 that is federal funded
page 1141 is accounting unit
2851 out of
school out of um out of school career
Pathways and on that same page uh 1141
we have accounting unit 3014 which is
special education State repr Pap if I
may just going back to the out of school
career
Pathways it's all federal fund so I'm
not going to you know worry too much
about it but I do notice the zeros in 27
could you that was a fiveyear grant all
right so basically the Federal grant
ends and we are wrapping up the program
that's how everything was scheduled to
be exactly there you go thank you you're
welcome on page 1142 we have 3015 which
is our court ordered
placements those are F education trust
funds for the
moment page 1143 we have school
nutrition this is the state matching
funds to all of the other federal
funds that's accounting unit 3029
on page 1144 we have another food
nutrition Child Nutrition technical Tech
Grant accounting unit
correct on page 1145
we have our robotics education fund
accounting unit
4021 page 1146 is our CTE voke Ed
Federal account
426 followed by accounting unit 4027
which is our voke Ed State account
page 1148 we have our accounting unit
4028 which is a Apprenticeship Training
fund
1149 is our accounting unit
4037 this is our federal adult education
grant
we have the next Grant uh accounting
unit 4039 is our state adult education
funds page 1152 we have
4045 house high school equival
equivalency this is our highet funds
then the next accounting unit is 5060
that system of care grant that was I
believe also a 5-year grant that has
expired on page
1153 accounting unit
57 5707 was our covid close out funds
and then page
1154 there's our computer science
education program accounting unit 67
6379 those were onetime
funds page 1155 is accounting unit 6401
which is our learner support
on page 1156 we have
6619 stronger connections that is a
Federal
grant sure um I just Mr chair I'm
looking at page um
1155 account 6401 the learner
support um specifically line 102
contracts for program Services it looks
look like that goes way
up that is do you describe what's
happening yes we have um we're looking
to implement
contracts um for our new special
education system Student Learning System
um rolling out these systems and
providing trainings for these
systems I don't know if you want to expi
anymore if they need
more well and that was also budgeting
for the uh special education audit if we
need to proceed with that so we put in
some funding to be able to to do an RFP
for that that
work uh the is this um part of the the
ask for each or for the Departments of
prioritized needs does this have to do
with
um the learning platform no thank you
for the question it is actually for a
couple of projects but one is the um
special education is currently we have a
a very old system that has of all of our
um student Information Systems so we are
rolling out a new one that's going to
take place over the next couple of years
so we were able to
utilize some of our covid relief funds
to get that project started then we
braided in some federal funds and then
we're um U utilizing some State funds to
be able to um do the whole project so
that there's a braiding of funds to
support the work so that we have a new
special education information system
that can Pro provide us with more robust
data more robust information and is more
user friendly and um kind of a timely as
well that's going to connect with our
existing Alma system that Caitlyn
Davis's team has rolled out for the
years will this be providing more
specific data regarding individual EP
costs and that and at the same time
you're working with the local districts
to provide that information is that all
part of this yes it'll be the training
we definitely need a lot of training on
how to utilize the new system okay and
is this also Rel to the
Medicaid funding system that you have
you're having to bring in no that's a
that is not part of the
Medicaid um system I think that's
something that DHHS is working on
separately okay so I have heard the
commissioner speak in other um places
regarding the the the melding of those
two because you have Medicaid issues in
not issues the wrong word but um
potential for Medicaid funds in your
world as well correct and eventually
you'll need to capture those through
your systems possibly and the local will
have to through the same thing through
their systems I think it's something
that would be phased in So currently the
project right now would not include that
but we could look further down the road
in adding that ability so what do you
expect in terms of the the types of data
the kind of data how much data you
expect from what you're doing right now
so currently right now with the
invoicing system and I think we've
talked a little bit about this with
special education Aid is that the the
invoices are all submitted almost kind
of in a shoe box but not really I mean
it's it's upload of information into a
system and then we we're going in we're
looking at it we're then seeing those
services are they in the IEP are the
hour correct and so we're doing a lot of
that work manually whereas this new
system everything would be more in real
time and more um alignment so it
wouldn't require that manual going
through and review because the
students's IEP would be in there and
then they could automatically you know
enter those costs and right now it's a
very analog type of system where we're
just uploading documents as opposed to
being able to go in and see that
information in in a system in a
dashboard type of uh format will part of
that require the local district one of
the I as I understand one of the issues
is the local districts kind of make up
their own descriptions or accounts or
whatever in their reporting so there's
not a consistency across the state in
terms of how they report these things is
is it going to help to address that
problem or I misunderstand that problem
yes it will help to address that problem
okay so they're being brought on board
the local districts are being brought on
board of So currently they have to use
our our system so they'll have to
continue to use this new system that we
roll out right they're being brought on
board with a new approach if you will
correct okay thank you great and when's
that when do you expect to start just
have the results of that I appreciate
the question so our our aim is actually
to be able to in about a year to be able
to have those schools that already have
the system um that they're utilizing our
our Alma districts is what we like to
call them that they're already using
that as a student information system so
in about a year next January we're
looking at being able to kind of roll
out with those and then uh a full
implementation hopefully
Statewide in Fall of
2026 and does part of that involve their
District's reporting not waiting till
like June 30 or whatever it is when you
get everything sort of throughout the
year or is it still going to be all at
the end I think the hope is going to be
or we're aiming for having more
consistent uploading of that
documentation but again be because of
the way the legislation is written it
does require us to kind of go through
and zero out other things before they
can apply for that special education Aid
so we often times they don't know their
numbers until the end but we're going to
work on trying to have more timely
uploading of the of the potential costs
so that they're able to see more in real
time what what that looks like for those
students does that mean it sound like
you refer to legislation it didn't sound
like you did refer to legislation is
there changes that can be made that
would help your process well I think
right now the time frame that's actually
in statute we may have to just look at
that once we are a little bit further
along in our process maybe for for next
year thank you any more questions around
here thank
you so on page
1157 we have accounting unit
7098 special ed co-curricular activities
and on page 393 not page no same page
accounting unit 3936 we have granted
Advance
corporation that is a Federal Grant I
believe that's a fiveyear grant
also and then we move that's the end of
learner report okay thank
you we move
to Workforce Innovation you have any
questions I have Rich Salah here for VR
anyways so the first thing you'll see is
on page 1160 you'll see the accounting
unit 2537 be our admin
program and it's all zero that's because
everything we've moved everything this
is another federal reporting thing so
we've moved instead of having two VR
accounts and trying to figure out the
federal reporting we've changed the way
that we're um um documenting things
internally in the office so that we can
do the federal reports more efficiently
so we've moved all of the funds into one
V
account which what is that account 253
2538 is that on the next page might be a
couple pages over
that's on page 1161 so you'll see that
there is an increase in the funding and
that is why you see the increase in the
funding is because we took two accounts
and made it into one accounting
unit so then we have accounting unit
2539 which is our supported employment
account on page 1163 we have accounting
unit
2542 independent Services Part
B the same page we have our accounting
unit 2543 interpreter certifications
on page
1164 accounting unit 2544 is independent
Services blind
State on page 1165 we have our John
Nesmith fund accounting unit 2547
thank you I'm just curious about the
John nesp because it's it's a new fund
apparently and was there an additional
uh money added to it for um the trust
fund I assume someone set up a trust
fund in his name for a particular
purpose and it looks like the fund is
growing or how much you know what I'm
saying I do okay thank you it it it
really is not a new fund there were no
funds spent in it last year in 24
um so this is again an interest bearing
fund so the fund is actually growing
that's why we've had additional
Appropriations you're
welcome on page 1166 we have our vending
stands 25 accounting unit
2548 followed by accounting unit 2549
independent Services blind Federal
and that is all of the VR programs the
next one is our accounting unit 2550 on
page 1168 which is our disability
determination Services
account yes and there were several
positions as the commissioner discussed
that we were looking to get rid of so
that count of 7 I don't know if it would
go down by like 10 maybe I don't
remember the count
exactly um oh we do have one
more independent Services Part B state
is accounting unit 30006 on page
1169 and then our last accounting unit
in that division is 3474 office of early
childhood and that oh NOP I'm sorry I
misspoke on page 1170 we have our cart
provider accounting unit
5715 that is a new accounting unit
revolving
funds I think we developed that
accounting unit in anticipation of
receiving funds through a fee the cart
oh this
so yeah uh this was because um we
recognized that we had a um we have an
RSA that allows us to um provide tuition
to cart uh providers and interpreters um
if if um those funds were available we
could we could use it but we didn't have
any place to put it we just recognized
that we did but we haven't used it in
quite some time so
it does and I was afraid you were going
to ask
that I'll have to get back to you I
can't
remember and so that ends that Division
and then we move on to the education
trust fund
okay Caitlyn will come back up
so on page 1171 we have the education
trust fund Administration accounting
unit
and just on this particular um item I'm
looking at
um line 010 looks look like we're having
some additions here so these are the
positions that we kind of talked about
before that had been been spread out
throughout the different accounting
units they all work on our state systems
our data systems and so we've moved them
here so we can really see what the cost
of operating our state systems are and
then they're being built back as fed as
appropriate so um some of these
positions one of them I can think of
collects um College and Career Readiness
indicators and so that's about 25% of
their time and that's something that's
required of the federal assessment Grant
so 25% of their time will be buil back
to the federal assessment Grant um some
of these are just um it's it's really
more just of a kind of a TR up of of
where the positions actually the work
that they're doing and the support that
they're doing versus you know where they
were living because if a position was
before like living under a federal
assessment Grant the federal assessment
Grant was being built for additional
costs associated that with that position
which is really not allowable um and so
that's really what we did here with this
budget
repr papich thank you I just wanted to
jump into that question that wasn't
answered earlier a bit of U quick
searching seems to Define cart as
Communications access realtime
translation so and since ASL is American
Sign Language we have a general
understanding of what that budget item
is for sure communication access real
time translation card
it's one of the many frankly weird
acronyms that the the government
sometimes use to make sure regular
people have no idea what they are
reading about so honors to God but you
know this is from the new HDH New
Hampshire DHHS by the
way all right so moving on to page
1173 we have the education trust fund
as you can see this is accounting unit
3043 we have a lot of zeros in this
banial budget and those are the accounts
that were moved those are the funds
lines that were moved to their own
individual accounting
unit
um so you'll see the first one 3445 on
that same page Charter Schools starts
out as zeros for 2425 and then it has
$66 million for 262
seven
and and you'd have to like look at
Charter
Schools and then go back up to
accounting unit
3043 and find the charter schools which
is in that accounting unit class 611 to
see that it was 60 million 61 million
and then come back down to this
accounting unit to be able to see how
the money flows I should add relist to
Charter Schools we have additional
information that we can provide um after
this or after lunch I know you have the
whole day budgeted to the Department of
Education so we have more adequacy
charter schools and EA handouts I just
we don't need to keep everybody else
here to to do that so we want to do that
later so on page
1174 we have the education Freedom
accounts again that does tie back to the
accounting unit 3043
on page
1175 we have 3447 which is the EFA phase
out
grants the next accounting unit is 3478
which is State
Testing I know it can be a little
challenging
with on
page 1176 we have our school building
Aid and this is just the tail so there
are no additional new projects in
that accounting unit 3998 is building
Aid lease
on page
1177 we have our special education
Aid on page 1178 we have accounting unit
40 oh I'm sorry yeah yeah on that one
both that one and the previous account
the funding is Grants non
Federal
correct correct so what does that refer
to what in those two instances that's
how that was the change that admin
Services wanted us to do they wanted us
to um follow their chart of accounts
which prior so if you look at the
special special education Aid in
accounting unit
43 it was a class 629 which was created
specifically for that counting unit and
they wanted us to move away from
creating special classes and instead use
the existing classes so in this example
These funds that are going to the
schools are grants but they're not
federal grants they're State F state
grants state grants okay that's um so
you'll see that so that would be just to
put it in my in terms I understand that
would be part of the adequacy formula
that we that's the catastrophic Aid
funding that okay thank you yeah
really sure
so we did building Aid did we and 3998
on page 1176 was building eight lease I
might re be repeating my oh I
am on Page 1178 is accounting unit 4074
that's tuition and transportation those
are our matching funds to our Perkins
Grant and
then accounting unit 4076 is a cell
phone free education
grant cell phone free not a free
education
grant um and
that concludes our
budget question
so we're hearing on the news that the
new secretary of
education federally is is saying we're
going to send you all just a block grant
have you started to plan for how that's
going to work out and I I think we
really need to see the language that
they use to do that first but we do have
Grant methodologies that could work here
in New Hampshire already so Title One
For example is for for educationally
disadvantaged students we have in our
adequacy formula a formula we use for
educationally disadvantaged students
where we heavily wait free and reduce
lunch and equalize valuations um that's
the extraordinary needs Grant so there's
no reason why something like the
existing extraordinary needs grants
couldn't be used um for uh determining
that but we really want to see the
language before um before we we spent a
lot of time and effort going down One
path and then they've said something
entirely different so any changes going
to make in the legislature probably be
in the second year we we wouldn't know
in time to get it done well we likely
wouldn't need legislation to do it um
because um because we have the funds
budgeted already in just a generic Grant
Line it's just the way that it's it's
distributed so and you expect to get
roughly the same amount or maybe more
we're certainly hopeful we'll get the
same amount but there has been little
Communications thank you
other
questions
PR go ahead p and Phillips uh I'm just
looking at the hospital 2 um spreadsheet
that the commissioner walked through
briefly this morning and um I'm looking
at item number three the adequacy final
calculation if I'm understanding
correctly um
schools update
their uh you
know they out update the Department of
Education twice a year for this purpose
but the department is asking for only
one calculation is that right no that's
that is not correct um so schools have
two major dead lines but then schools
sometimes change your data after those
deadlines and so what we're really
asking for is that we run adequacy on
October 1st of every year and we give it
to Department of Revenue and Department
of Revenue uses that to to set tax rates
and then we use that against our tax
warrant to say like how much they have
to raise after after the amount they're
getting um then for some reason and I
think this has existed before the
Department of Education had the quality
Data Systems that we do now the law
requires us to go in and recalculate
again in April of the year so right now
in March we are recalculating it again
for April 1st um most of the schools
haven't their data hasn't changed at all
um but some schools have had one or two
kids change here and there they would be
identified the previous year the
department doesn't really feel that
there is any um value in that exercise
of rerunning it a second time um so we
just asked to take that out of the
requirements now we did want to build
something in if a school did for some
reason forget a whole bunch of kids the
previous year somehow they determined
all of their they forgot all of their
freedom juice lunch kids we wanted to
say well we do want to have a mechanism
for that but because it's so far and few
between we don't want to have to do it
for all schools especially because it's
after the tax rates are being said so we
didn't think that had any
value Dy please don't take this as
anything other than something to help
you as a new person when I'm going
through all of this obviously I don't
know all the acronyms that you're using
obviously I don't understand all the
grant processes and what have you the
accounting is accounting however it
would really behoove me or maybe others
if in your if you had a separate sheet
and you put down everything that you
explain because you're here look how
many of you are here not that we don't
want you here I don't imagine but we're
wasting your time asking questions that
a little footnote for each one why it
changed and it went to here you know
this one's being eliminated this one's
being added whatever it might be might
help all of us and prepping us for now
this is just me maybe the rest of you
don't feel that way um to ask you more
pertinent questions that you wouldn't
that we wouldn't necessarily think about
because we're so focused on okay where
did this go what's that you know what
I'm saying we can look at that for
future presentations and it might save
you time too you know
so where are we going from
here do you want to talk about charter
schools in adequacy
today so as you all know there's there's
you know $1.23 billion dollar of
Education trust fund Appropriations that
the department is prepared to take a
deeper dive into they have additional
handouts so so District adequacy efas
Charter Schools plus we can talk about
the other specific uh levels of funding
that the governor proposed um you have
45 minutes now before lunch you could
start maybe take a break and then come
back and finish probably won't get
everywhere you want to get to this
morning but we might as well use the
time maybe I don't know if people need a
break before getting into that or just
want to keep going can you last for 45
minutes and then just take a a five
minute break you a five minute break
right now okay go
ahead you all can take a break too if
you want for five minutes
stretch my legs
for
e
e e
Hey listen I didn't go to bed until 2:30
this morning
so the first thing I'd like to do if I
could get the committee
back repres chairman
wer G if you want thank you that's why
you
ped TR to throw it down just in case I
guess so the first thing I want to do is
talk to the committee separate from the
group uh the people presenting they've
asked there's two particular people that
are here that could cover a couple
things and then be done if possible if
we have questions the two areas are the
spe special education catastrophic Aid
and the
building Aid building is that what it
was building Aid yes yeah so the
question is to the committee
representative wer this includes you um
do do folks here have questions they
would like to ask about first of all
let's take catastrophic
Aid special education catastrophic
Aid and and specifically so there's
amounts that are in the budget the
governor changed those amounts we've had
robust conversations about these grants
at this point in front of this committee
and the house funding policy commit or
house funding committee um and our
question really to you is what else do
you need from the Department to be able
to make a decision relative to the
budget and where you want to go
for both building Aid and catastrophic
Aid State special education
Aid mate go
ahead I guess it would help me um as you
know I'd like the narrative and perhaps
you can take us back and just go through
you sort of not NE I don't want a
history but um just a narrative of how
this has spun out and what you see in
the future of what you know we're here
to try to help you what your needs are
going to be um how you would see
catastrophic Aid develop or
undevelop thank you for the question and
I'm going a little bit off the cuff here
my computer died the battery the
battery's done so when we were looking
at um doing the
Appropriations a few years back for this
bium at that time the
33.5 is Million Dollar was in alignment
with what we were anticipating so now
that the cost this year being 50 million
we it wasn't really something we would
have anticipated years ago and so that's
why we we have that a shortfall with the
appropriation and we're seeking the the
16 million to to kind of make up or that
is in the governor's uh budget to kind
of make up that 16 million and then
going forward we're looking at funding
it at 50 million but I I think that it
it was
few years before that I think we were at
22 million I at the top of my head I
could be wrong about that and
maybe it's on
page page
1177 it's a county unit
4073 that will show you what the
governor's proposed but you have to
remember this is one of those accounts
that shifted if you want to see the
history it's on page 117
3 are you in the middle of finishing
your thoughts or yes okay representer
chairman wer this CAD a it shouldn't
come as a surprise at the end of the
year that we're 50 million behind or
whatever the figure was we should be
getting periodic updates otherwise we're
not going to approve them I mean you
can't just decide at the end of the year
oh gee we went thousands of dollars over
what we thought they knew that all along
they just didn't bother to let anybody
know well I think it's a little bit
thank you for the question it's a little
bit um challenging because the way that
it's written it and you're doing the
formula after the fact and so they have
to you know look at spending down one of
the things that we looked at too was
ensuring that you utilized all of your
federal funds here making sure you
utilized all of your um the available uh
Sesser funds that came specifically for
special education AIDS so we did have
them go through to make sure like you
utilized all of these then we're looking
at calculating the formula based on
those
costs in in AAR and so it takes time for
us to go through and to be able to
review all of that it I I think we've
talked a little bit about what are some
ways we could
possibly structure this so that we have
the ability to do it more up to date but
I think that we're a bit limited by how
it's written because we have to follow
the timeline specifically so but the
questions I was asking you earlier
regarding what you're doing over the
next few years is it's hoping to address
some of what representative wer was
Raising yes we want to be able to um imp
A system that to do more of this in real
time because again we you know we were
functioning kind of here's your box of
receipts at years ago youed to take to
your account okay figure out everything
that happened for me last year we're
getting away from that so that it can be
done in more real time and also so that
it can help the districts kind of look
at in real time what's what's going on
and how they're they're looking at those
expenses does that help
um repres papait thank you Mr chair
so when uh chairman asked earlier what
would you like I have a list but I know
that you also are not in a position to
deliver on that because what I really
want is to understand that the
Department of Education at some point in
the future will have the ability to
really drill down into the special
education cost at the student level if
needed and just understand both what's
going on which I understand today with a
current reporting you guys cannot do
that that I get it and also taking it
one step further down that road once we
start understanding how much we are
spending for every service for every
child there is a database that again the
department can look at and analyze right
then hopefully we'll be able to to see
if there is any way to standardize or
find appropriate cost for some of those
and services and uh you know determine
whether there are more cost effective
ways for the various school districts to
find the same Services you know to offer
the same services but maybe have a you
know broader contract from the state
that uh gets better prices and so on
obviously this is far down the road but
just in terms of the long term in the
meantime we'll Soldier on with what we
have so uh I I really appreciate how
hard you guys are working I understand
right now you cannot get that data and
that frustration that chairman wer was
expressing about only knowing post facto
that we have a cost overrun and not just
post facto but like half a year after
the school year ended obviously that's a
process that needs fixing but you guys
are in the process of fixing it so uh
we'll patiently wait and support you on
the way so we can get there thank
you maybe this will help as well um so
yall should be aware that the education
funding committee has a bill coming to
the floor this week specifically related
to this uh catastrophic Aid situation um
and specifically related to the pration
um component of it so the governor has
as they indicated added more money into
the budget to essentially cover what if
if the if it doesn't increase yet
further um and that bill currently
before the current will be coming before
the house um sets a specific floor on
the pration value if you will so go
ahead represent
Murray yeah I was just wanted to follow
up with um you know the I guess the the
problems of pration um how it impacts
the school districts and um it seems in
the past few
years the amount that's been priated
back to the school has increased it's
gotten was like at 20% for a while was
there point where it reached 30% or can
you you know can you give some history
as to um because it's not fully funded
how it goes back to the
schools are you talking about for the if
that 16 million would were to be
appropriated or are we talking about the
past in the past hopefully going forward
that would not be an issue so we um did
provide a document to you that looked at
from 2007 to about
2025 that had the that pration amount so
it it has fluctuated throughout the year
so it's like you know we're at 100% And
then about in 2012 we got to a point
where we were at that
69% and then we were able to go in uh
and add in funds slowly but we were
still at that 70% range until we got to
uh 2020 where it did go up to
30.8 and then that's when we were at
that 94 to 100% so I think the
challenges there's an amount that's
appropriated that's all we can spend
we're going to have to prate
it if the legislation was worded where
we were able to draw down funds then we
don't have to do the pration part or the
pration is taken out I think I've seen
some legislation that uh proposed taking
out that pration and then the ability to
draw down those funds but I'm not sure
so I mean right now we have to go with
the way that it's written um which this
year put us at that 69% last year was 7%
the year before that 98% 100% so we were
meeting um Our obligation for the most
part until this
year so so the bill the bill I'm
referring to if I'm not mistaken you
correct me if I'm wrong here it sets a
floor on the probation of 80% is that
yeah yeah that was a wooden drop below
80% with with this bill and they'd have
a warrant to draw in order to satisfy
that
and just to um talk about planning right
because one of the stresses that this
creates to school districts is that
they're attempting to budget and they
don't know what level to Budget on this
you know particular aid for and they
hope to get 100% and actually the
department has done pretty well lately
in getting that 100% or close to it
until the last budget cycle when uh you
know everything seems to have exploded
into terms of cost and everybody again
we were told earlier this morning that
the school budgets are like 60 million
over on that line so there has been a
unexpected spike in special education
caost that you know we couldn't address
but the reason why the bill coming to
the floor has a a floor on it is that
while the idea is to give every school
district 100% of what they aim for at
least this way they can budget for 80%
and know that it won't get below that
so you know trying to guarantee 100%
probably is not fiscally possible so we
try to do the best we can to give the
schools the predictability while at the
same time not heading straight into uh
an expected cost overun
so when Mark gets up here too he can
talk you through really how it works
when a District budget is prepared and
then when the tax rates are sent too so
we could do that as part part of Mark's
presentation kind of Step by Step
because that's probably an important
piece for the committee to understand
and this is part of that but adequacy is
part of that as his building Aid
so goe I was just saying you know having
the 80% floor I can see the value in
that but if you're looking at
percentages that still doesn't help the
school district know exactly how much
they're going to have to pay um not
knowing what they'll have to expend on
for any particular student for special
ed so I see it gives a a binder it gives
a range but um you know it's 80% of an
unknown
number and that's part of why this fund
was originally developed was the state
catastrophic Aid fund was because school
district would have a high cost special
education kid move in and they wouldn't
necessarily have budgeted for that kid
um or in some of these small school
districts some of these kids cost could
be a large percentage of their budget
and so that's why we had State special
education funding outside of the
adequacy formula which provides a base
amount for all special education kids we
were saying No this amount right here is
a uh we want to help school districts in
response to these high special education
costs um associated with with certain
children represent D in terms of that
would it be advantageous for the funds
to follow the student to the next
District they do they do yes so those so
it's paid one year in AAR and so the way
it works is so if I attended conquered
high school for half the year and my
cost for
$100,000 um and conquered High School U
or conquered School District it's
probably an auto District placement but
conquered School District um occurred
$50,000 of my cost and then I moved to
hopkington halfway through the year and
then hopkington paid for the rest of the
50,000 um we split that up for to the
different schools because it's because
we don't make the so we just made a
payment in January of 25 um that was for
school year 23 24 so the way it works is
school districts go through the entire
year they figure out all of the costs
associated with a certain child they
submit that to the Department of
Education the Department of Education
calculates what the allowable costs are
and then what the formula would project
and then the pration and then we make
the payments in the in the following
fiscal
year other questions on this topic okay
I guess you are released thank you for
staying a little extra time
same same question relative to building
Aid um what do you go ahead because the
committee we've presented some materials
um you know we explained how the tail
works the new projects Works everything
like that
um to make sure that you are in a place
to make a decision in what three weeks
here two weeks now what what else do you
need from me and my team to to make you
successful I'm interested to hear about
um
the applicants that are currently in the
pipeline for this goor round who
potentially will not be serviced so I'm
just wondering is it the same folks from
before is it a bunch of new people what
what does that so um class look like you
may remember me saying that there was a
change in the law that was probably
helpful to the way the building aid
program works but is going to upset
division 2 and this is specifically what
I mean um so the way that program was
changed is the Department of Education
accepts application s annually now each
year we have a list we keep that list
once you are on the list you get to stay
on that list until you're offered
funding um so this is really the first
year of that happening in the and so you
being on division 2 before are used to
us showing up with the list and saying
here's who the funding would go to
because in the past the department had
that information by January 1 of each
year um so um I did present the
committee a copy on February 5th um of
the existing list and I can send that
again if you don't have it but that
that's what our existing list is um we
are accepting applications right now and
should have additional projects added to
that list um after they are ranked so
the applications are due to the
Department of Education on April 1st
then the Department of Education goes
through a fairly rigorous ranking
process and then the State Board of
Education will validate that list and
publish that list I believe it's by July
1 of each year but I'm not actually sure
on the publication date of that list so
it will not be available in time for for
the budget however you have a list of I
think about 13 projects right now so I
think it's safe to say that um if you
were to provide funding in building
eight it would likely go to the 13 that
are on that list before it would go to
new
applications and just as a followup um
if we're only appropriating for the tail
that means folks who have spent money on
um their application
process um but because we're not funding
any new projects we'll miss out on
another cycle that is correct um that is
one of the advantages of the new program
though because in the past you had to
submit an application each year for the
list and now when you've you've
submitted that application you get to
stay on that list and there's um a way
for uh schools to update their costs
associated with the project and stay on
the list and that's that's one of the
things that was heavily talked about and
debated when um the program was was
Rewritten
repr papich thank you so just a quick
question which you kind of answered but
I want to make sure I understand it
correctly obviously it's a good thing
that people don't have to reapply every
year especially since most information
is the same so why would you have to um
but I think you indicated that we don't
really reced the list every year right
so if I was number one last year will I
still be number one this year or at the
end of the submission period we take the
people who were already on the list and
the new people on the list and Shuffle
everything from scratch we do we do not
rerank the list so who is number one
right now will stay number one and like
one through 13 or 1 through 17 on the
list will stay exactly the same and then
number one from the new ranking pool on
April 1st this year will become the next
one on the list understood so there is
no situation in which the ranking could
change based on the changes in the
district circumstances over the years so
what could change change um is the
percentage the state would provide so um
at the time when we award the money a
school district is eligible for 30 to
60% of the project costs um when you
look at their equalized valuation and
median family income um or might be free
and reduced lunch percentage um and so
that amount could change so if a school
district were to get substantially poor
so they submitted two years ago they're
on our existing list right now and all
they all of a sudden they have a lot
more free and reduced lunch kids in the
district they're maybe they were only
going to get 30% of their project in the
past they may get 60% of their project
this year okay but none of the factors
that go into the ranking would be
reassessed correct oh yeah well that's a
policy thing obviously the department
does what the legislation ask them to do
I find it to be a bit strange policy
that if a new school has a compelling
case that would normally put them at
number one they cannot get onto the list
because the first 10 spots are taken but
as I said that's the legislation and the
policy and we deal with it as is right
now so thank
you representative Ro but that changes
if somebody drops off right we talked
about that somebody might drop off and
then the next one comes up next one
comes up right and then there's others
that probably decide well we can't do
this because there's no funding so you
know correct correct and they don't
necessarily need to drop off either they
just can say we're not we're not going
to do it this year they'll still stay on
there but somebody below them the money
representative Murray thank you um
school districts have to have Community
buying to do a project you know they
have to raise their own funds right do
warrants run out are there is there a
time limit on warrants I just I'm asking
because I simply don't know um is if a
school is bumped and bumped and bumped
over like you know we're not there's
nothing on the budget for this year so
that's putting it out for another one to
two years for schools do warrants get
reconsidered or do you know anything
about that I don't CU they could lose
their they could lose their commity
support potentially yeah I I think they
would have to put it back on the ballot
because they would have to do a bond
based on the time of the warrant and I
I'll verify that for you but I'm I'm
pretty sure that it would need to be
come on MAR Cas you're needed don't be
uncomfortable specific question I don't
think okay just just might as well be
there just in case come on up Mark with
your articles I just don't know
what's repres papovich on the warrant
article the warrant article is good for
that year so you got your approval in
March if you happen to get the funding
rate you can go forward if not you're
going to have to go back on the ballot
every year so that I mean unless the
warrant language specifies it's a you
know nonlinguistic
and so on so the and part of the way the
the program was redesigned was because
to allow schools to have an idea that
the state would be providing funding so
now a town Bas the formula the way that
kind of works now is the state budget
will be finalized then we will be able
to offer funding to certain people on
the list then they can take that and
generate their warrant and then go to
vote and they have up to three times
based on the timing of you know when
when the funding is is made a aailable
to pass that locally um where in the
past it kind of was backwards and then
we were having people not be able to
take advantage of that and that's what
we don't want
so
um without having any funding at all
this year no funding projects that could
potentially go back to some schools
would communities who passed a warrant
uh the warrant after a year would not be
enforced anymore and they would have to
do another warrant in order to continue
potentially to get refunding is that
kind of what is that what I'm hearing
assuming that the warrant is contingent
on them receiving State funding um they
could certainly go through go through
and build the project entirely with
local funds yeah right um after
everything has been approved I'm trying
to think I'm trying to avoid a um a
school kind of getting into getting
stuck in the mud here um when do they
start the project so assuming that they
have the warrant and they've been
approved um how much time do they have
before they can actually I mean that
really that really depends locally um
because the school districts have to get
all of the contracts in order and and
some of them are ready to go basically
the day that warrant passes I mean
really the warant is for the next school
year to so right now in March they're
voting and for the next budget year so
you really need to wait to get that but
it's it's across the the
board I will you know obviously second
your earlier comments they are correct
some districts are ready to put a shovel
in the ground really quickly some may
need to do a bit of preliminary work
retain something and so on I would say
that based on my understanding of what
has happened in the state most schools
are pretty close to shovels otherwise
they would have a hard time coming with
a good estimate to put on the warrant so
because of that they tend to really kind
of have it Tien down but again year over
year you have new contracts inflation
change in availability of suppliers and
so on right yeah t typically the project
plan is very well developed at the time
I mean it's needed for the application
so a lot of the architect work has been
done design work the engineering design
work has been done relative to the
project to help them associated with
costs so it's really just where they
like on getting all their contracts
signed going out to RFP and all of all
of that work yeah and very importantly
the doe does not impose a timeline once
you are approved they will just
patiently wait as you are going through
your stages and wait for you to meet
your milestone in these bir so it's
appropriate right the doe doesn't have a
now you got to finish in 5 years or your
funds are gone finish corre but you do
have to start your project within a
certain of course you cannot just sit on
the funds forever but as long as
progress is made there is a lot of
flexibility from the doe in terms of the
timeline and how long it may take we are
actually working with a school right now
who I think was approved in 2019 to
finalize their project so
okay looks like we're clear on the
building Aid so I guess you can be
excused Mark have a great
day Mark is out of oh he's adequacy who
was the other person had to go was it
just Mark oh just Mark yeah and I was
going he's not really
going uh do you want to do lunch though
now that it's almost noon yeah that's
what I'm wondering so um that was my
next question should we
this is a commission for our committee a
question for our committee do you all
want a break now rather than sort of
starting something and interrupting it
and
then go ahead um so kayin brought
introduce yourself Mark Mell Bureau
School finance department of education
um just one thing kayin brought up about
the mechanics of how special education
Aid work and I think we've talked about
this as a committee before um so when
districts T typically you're doing your
budget throughout the fall and then
you're presenting it to the voters in
the spring and so they have to plug in
Revenue estimates and they're
essentially telling their voters um they
make their best guess and they don't
have they don't know what the future
holds um so they'll plug in a number for
special education Revenue that they
think they're going to get and they'll
tell their voters that and then if you
go to town meeting of course people say
I can't want to don't want don't want to
give you an estimated tax rate because
it's really hard to estimate but they'll
try their best to give the voters an
idea of what they think is going to be
the tax bill um and so um when they're
making those estimates they might assume
special education Aid will continue
without pration and so if pration does
happen later basically the revenue
estimates that they talked with their
voters when they passed the budget it's
not going to be there so um then when
when we have more recent uh more current
data and taxes are being set that was
that's when that pration really gets
communicated out um to the uh saus and
so from there maybe they might have
assume that special education was going
to come in it gets paraded and then the
tax bill is higher than maybe they
advertised to town me meeting so that's
that's sort of the effect of pration as
far as they're expecting that money to
come in didn't fully come in it got it
got prated and so that's sort of
mechanically what happens at the
district
level fully agreed in an Ideal World the
school district being aware of the
possibility of pration would have some
unassigned f fund balance they can use
rather than increased taxes or would
have some Reserve funds set aside for
special education but I will say on the
record that that's an ideal practice and
not every District in a position to
implement those you know but those those
practices would decrease the odds of
having to send a tax bill that's higher
than expected but again not every
district has the ability to do so and
the districts that are more at risk are
the very small ones where just a little
bit of variation can be a very big you
know impact relative to the overall size
of the budget when when I'm talking with
districts too I always say use your
professional judgment as far as coming
up with Revenue numbers so with adequacy
uh we typically say don't budget 100%
budget 95% because that's the guarantee
um districts could budget for 100% And
tell their voters that number um so um
they have they have a lot of discretion
there as far as how they talk with their
voters uh but that's just how that how
that works but if I'm not mistaken
despite the shortfall in special
education funding in school budgets
there was not a shortfall in overall
funding I.E they had surpluses in other
areas of their budgets that actually
covered their cost is that that um so
depends on District by District but over
but overall there's there's excess there
was excess funding and then that lapses
back to the taxpayers in the form of an
unassigned fund balance or not or or not
it's for some districts it does not yeah
so just to be clear it actually was not
like they did not get like they didn't
have the adequate funding in their
school budgets for the most part so make
that did you another they did they did
have adequate funding because they had
surpluses in other areas of their
budgets um represent thank you um you
know a student comes into a classroom uh
with the special needs um they're very
high can can you speak to consistency of
what those costs are across years
because I think in most cases the
student would stay in the same school
district the student would still have
the same issues one year to the next so
can does is there anything to be learned
by the school district in terms of of U
projecting some of these costs because
of consistency of the needs of that
student through that that particular
school do you know understand what I
can't really speak to the individual
student level cost um but I think I
think you're I think what you're saying
is reasonable in a sense that the cost
you had the previous year for the same
student you'd expect it to be pretty
well correlated with the next year um uh
but I can't really speak to that in any
like data
way but this is exactly why this whole
special education thing is so
frustrating it's not about individual I
don't think it's about individual
student cause changing from year to year
it's something else that's going on in
the system one thing that happened this
particular year was this is the first
year that we had you may recall that we
extended the age at which you aged out
by Year and that probably contributed
something I'm not actually able to get
the accurate answers to how much that
contributed um but in any case things
like that happen as well but there's
more going on than that and there's
definitely a problem with special
education fun and I don't mean at the
state level I mean
everywhere oh anyway I'm sorry uh any
other questions related to what are they
related to what are you speaking on
special education Aid okay you here who
are you who are you and why you here
well I know who he is and what he does
but okay so if that addresses that phase
then we'll take a lunch break now and
come back at 1:00 at yeah a little
before one and we do now um and then
we'll continue with the whole adequacy
piece this afternoon is that correct and
all the related
components I'm sure okay uh thank you
all
e
e e
all right we all
settled uh so it being way past one
o'clock we'll reopen the afternoon
session at uh
1:13 of uh division 2 the finance
committee and it's really open to you
all what you want to talk about so um
I'll let the folks at the table
introduce themselves and talk about what
they whatever you want to talk about but
then it's really up to the committee in
terms of questions that you have
regarding the basically the adequacy
formula and whatever else they present
here Mark Mello
sorry so we show 316 for 26 and 27 total
employees
or they ask what is the total presently
employed not the 306 but the real real
number um this afternoon we not we sck
around to talk about adequacy Char
schoola you don't have the total number
was it in the handout though for the
committee's uh Indulgence here so yeah
so they are prepared to talk about ETF
programs today but to answer your
question representative on the Doe's
hand out today I think they reported 63
vacant positions and they gave those big
lists that include ones the commissioner
identified could be abolished versus
ones he would prefer to retain so that's
I I don't have it handy have you looked
at the payroll things that came from the
treasurer no all right I'll look at
those thank
you so Mark Mello Bureau of school
finance department of education briany
and also School Finance
so we have um a few documents that you
should have in front of you um one is
the governor's recommended education
trust fund uh uh Appropriations for
2627 the other one is and they all kind
of look the same there's a district
adequacy handout that's uh kind of thin
there's a charter school handout a
little bit thicker and then um education
uh Freedom account handout as well so
what we're going to talk about is the
education trust fund programs and mainly
the uh those three programs the ones
that deal with State funding
formulas um
so especially to the new people um new
to division 2 and new to uh the state
budget process uh the education trust
fund is um uh this committee deals with
Surplus statements you deal with the
highway fund Surplus the fishing game
Surplus statement um that's really your
budgeting that's how you solve your
budget puzzle is through the Surplus
statement and so this committee is
unique in a sense the other divisions um
don't deal with Surplus statements as as
frequent as this commit does so um when
you're willing or when you're um uh to
the point where you're going to build
your education budget the Surplus
statement is going to be a key part of
that because it's going to tell you
Mickey's going to itemize it out um uh
as far as where what kind of education
programs you're going to fund through
the education trust fund now as as
Mickey and and chairman Wier talked
about there's discuss there's always
conversations about changing what the
education trust fund is going to look
like uh previous years the house has res
shifted the education trust fund pretty
dramatically and the Senate has put it
back to where maybe it was historically
but oh sorry sorry sorry sorry uh uh put
it back to um uh imaginary stupid I'll
try to use I'll try to use be careful
with my words put it back to the way the
governor presented it or Governor 35%
right right right right no went to 22%
they went to 44 CH chairman is correct
the most idiotic thing um so but but you
but you you make your decisions as far
as how you want to design the education
trust fund um there's some back back and
forth with the House and Senate there's
some history there as you can as you can
see um so but the the education trust
fund we're working with is the one the
governor has recommended so that's the
one we're going to talk about now um
just just a heads up conversations
obviously about it changing um just be
mindful of that and just to be clear
this isn't about changing education
funding it's just a question of the
balance between the education trust fund
and the general fund dollars where they
sit before they're spent and and that's
another thing too is the revenue revenue
splits you know what business that's all
that we're not going to talk about that
today and that's not something the
department does that's something Dr does
and that's something this committee
weighs and means all the legislature you
make those decisions um and it is
important for building your budget to
know where the revenue is going to be to
fund your programs um but what we're
going to talk about today is those
programs um which chairman ER talked
about um so um the other key thing again
uh seasoned veterans know about this the
way you budget education funding there's
hb1 which we just went through today we
went through all those Appropriations
and then there's warrants so you got to
know the difference between the two when
you give an appropriation in hb1 and
there is no warrant connected to it no
warrant Authority connected to it that's
it you've now finalize your funding for
that so if we look at State Testing if
you fund State Testing at 4.5 million in
hb1 uh uh for fiscal year 26 that's it
there's no warrant for that there so
there's no additional liability
Financial liability to the state you've
set it to what it is um but there's
certain programs that have warrants so
district adequacy has a warrant so
whatever you put into hb1 you could put0
in hb1 we have the authority and are
mandated to spend that money anyways so
instead of if if say you
put0 in hb1 for district adequacy we are
going to request that money and we are
going to spend that money because the
law tells us how to spend that money and
gives us the authority to do so and M us
to do so so with District adequacy
putting an hb1 number it's more just a
budgeting process um but it doesn't
actually we have warrant Authority so if
you put zero in there um if you
underfund it we're going to go draw on
that warrant and if you uh uh
underfunded we're just going to lapse it
back to the education trust
fund so basically just to summarize what
you are saying is that the adequacy
spending is driven by the number of
students and the amount per student and
their eligibility anything we put in hbi
hb1 is our best guess as to how much
that will be but at the end of the day
we'll spend whatever we'll spend Based
on data we don't have yet that that's
correct and and and what we're going to
talk about is if you're not going to
change state law so if you're not going
to change adequacy in state law and
there's some bills that are going to end
up in this committee or uh that um
actually haven't gone through the
process but there's usually bills that
are referred to this committee um that
seek to change adequacy that's actually
changing the program and that's actually
changing uh how many Stu might students
might be in in the program um that's
changing um U the actual amounts each
student aid amount could be so that
would actually change state law and that
would change the amount the state has to
pay um but for the numbers we're talking
about here it's you coming up with your
best estimate as far as what you think
it's going to be in the future based on
the law that you're enacting and based
on the student data you have and so
we're just going to walk through some of
that right now any questions no okay I
just want to iterate that adequacy was
just for adequacy it didn't include
building Aid it didn't include special
ed it didn't include tuition and
transportation those are always funded
from general fund except for this last
uh budget which was you
know which ended up with a big Surplus
that we couldn't spend anywhere else
yeah if you look at the history and I
think um um uh the commissioner and
Tammy's uh document will show you they I
don't think the history goes back as far
as you're talking about but they'll show
you the history of fund moving around
general fund programs moving to the
education trust fund and so uh there's
been a lot of changes throughout the
years and it's expanded the programs
used by the education trust fund that's
correct um so uh the first one we're
going to talk about is District
adequacy so District adequacy the
governor has recommended uh uh a billion
80 million um that's for fiscal year 26
and then for fiscal year 27 so if you
look at page 2 your sheet it has the
town by Town you're all familiar with
the fiscal year 26 estimate we've
provided that before um this is just the
town by town to get to what the uh the
governor has uh um put in the budget for
hb1 um that billion 82 million so that
is fiscal year 27 and so uh the
assumptions used in that there are some
assumptions used in that uh is
essentially a 1.2% decline an enrollment
between
26 uh um it's it's going to be 26 to 27
but really it's going to be school year
25 to school year 26 because adequacy is
one year
behind um so that billion 82 assumes
6.6% property growth um which is the
historical average um that property
growth number is not current property
it's the property uh now have to theatee
there's a lag on the property collection
so it's not going to be 6.6 as in um the
property data that's going to come in
this September it's from the previous
September um September 2024 once that
data has been equalized and analyzed by
Dr basically we're assuming the growth
of that data is going to be
6.6% which is pretty consistent with
historical property growth um so um as
you all receive the adequacy take a
question not as not as much a question
but just to make sure everybody's on the
same page my understanding is that we
are talking about the increase in
property values because certain elements
of the formula are calculated based on
equalized property values so if property
values increase really high we may have
to pay less funds in certain parts of
the formula and so on again we have some
people who are newer here and I just
wanted to make sure they know why we're
discussing that's that's an important
thing the reason why we now have
property estimates and historically the
LBA has not done property forecasting in
the formula and the Department of
Education is because of the significance
of the extraordinary needs Grant the
extraordinary needs Grant is a function
of free and reduced price meal counts
and property data and so if Property
Data uh property valuations if they grow
faster than
2.2% the adequacy formula is going to be
cheaper in the future because property
values are growing at a high rate um if
the property values were to tank the
adequacy formula would go up uh uh I
can't put a number for it but you could
make an estimate and you could forecast
where it would be this is um you all
might have opinions about the current
property Market um this is looking back
a year so this is old data uh moving
forward if properties are flat um it
could cost the state more an adequacy
formula through the extraordinary needs
Grant um the other variable um would be
free and reduced price meals so in this
estimate for fiscal year 27 we assume no
drop in poverty um so basically we we we
assume uh a drop in enrollment but
potentially poverty is going to stay the
same um and so we've kind of seen just
like we've seen Special Education data
um we've seen those numbers not really
drop so there's a higher percentage of
individuals was uh in special education
programs um as a percent of the student
population so we held those numbers
constant in our estimate we held poverty
constant in our estiment we increased
property values um and we declined to
moment a little bit so those are all the
assumptions that would go into that
formula we think that's a fair number we
don't know this number could be off by 5
million 10 million we don't know but we
think based on those assumptions um I
think we're happy with that and you
funding at this num this number um keep
in mind if something happens like
poverty skyrockets um adequacy would
become more expensive and you would have
to we would have to draw a warrant to
pay for it um so this is the challenge
you have as far as forecasting the
future we think these this is a fine
number for you to put there in your
budget for a little bit of context if I
could add to that Mark was talking about
warrants earlier so last bium in 2023 we
assumed we budgeted 1 b53 million for
fiscal 25 adequacy if you look at the
one pag or Mark just gave in ad in
fiscal 25 for adequacy it's 1 billi 64
million so it was $1 million off that
the department had to draw warrant so 1%
which is really not not that bad
considering you know 11 million seems
like a large warrant to have to draw but
on over a billion dollars it's not too
bad one of one of the yeah the the
percentages make us look good but 10
million is not I don't want to be off by
10 million again um and one of the
reasons why we were off was we had a
hard time forecasting poverty so f&r
data um the districts give us a
beginning of the year count of the
students they think are going to be free
and reduce price meals and we just sort
of use that data but through as the year
progress more students started accessing
fnr programs so poverty did increase
from what we thought it was going to be
when we did our first snapshot of data
collection and so it grew and that
caused the budget to be off by just the
nature of the extraordinary needs Grant
off by a lot that's why we're not
forecasting any drop in poverty so in
that way we're being conservative um of
course anything can happen to the data
um but that's where we're trying to
maybe correct not trying to overcorrect
but trying to correct for maybe that
mistake um or that that blip uh uh issue
before
um so that's our adequacy estimates uh
um that the um and this is the backup um
um and Mickey always talks with us
whenever he's building his adequacy town
by town or building estimates or working
with the committee to build your own
estimates um um we'll we'll always uh
quality control each other's work
there any questions about District
adequacy um yes we're good
the the next document really um again I
know you have no more questions about
District adequacy but page six um this
will just confirm everything that you
that you've already just heard you'll
notice we plugged in our our 1.2%
decline in
ADM uh page six of the district adequacy
one should look like this um again you
can see the you can see the numbers
yourself uh fnr numbers we have holding
steady special education numbers we have
holding steady ADM we have a 1.2%
decline so that's it for district
adequacy any
questions um and and what the governor
has proposed is exactly this and so um
no uh if you agree with these
assumptions in this estimate um you
would have to make no changes um however
of course um this Ed funding has been
looking at changes to adequacy and so
those bills might come uh uh before you
so now we're going to move on to Charter
Schools yeah we'll move on to Charter
Schools but just to go back to this
handout if we're going to enumerate all
the programs that potentially have a
financial uh uh cost to the state that
is unknown um there's District adequacy
which if we estimate is accurate then
then you're then the cost is the
estimate if then then you don't have any
unknown cost um there's Charter School
tuition um which has an EFA uh um uh has
a a a warrant Authority education
Freedom accounts um EFA phase out grants
which we'll talk about have warrant
Authority um down here towards the
bottom is kindergarten enrollment um So
currently a few districts are having
town meeting district meeting to
determine if they want to go from a half
funded kindergarten program to a full
day funded kindergarten program and
under state law if they go from full day
to so from half day to full day um uh we
have to increase their adequacy amount
um to cover that half day Delta because
when you think about adequacy adequacy
is one year behind so basically they
have to wait a full year to be paid for
1.0 ADM and so we fund them at half um
the missing half of an ADM that they
need and it's considered like a startup
Grant so it basically catches adequacy
up with real time um so there's four
districts considering it um if they go
ahead and pass it and have full day
kindergarten we are going to have to uh
uh uh Implement uh uh payout
kindergarten startup grants um we're
going to know more by the end of uh
tomorrow uh so we'll pass that
information along to the LBA so you'll
have that information which um which
Mickey would plug into the Surplus
statement because that also as warrant
Authority um and so that's will just be
a potential variable in your budgeting
um the other one is SAU merger grants if
any SAU uh
consolidates and uh um with another SAU
there's $200 per student that goes out
in a grant currently um we have received
no applications as far as districts
looking to merge or saus looking to
merge with each other um but if they did
that would be a cost to the state for
$200 a student um so the numbers here
are zero because we don't have any
information
wer why wouldn't it be a savings when
they merge so there there could be a
saving locally but to the state uh uh
the state the way the grant is the way
the bill was written and then enacted
into law was it's an SAU merger Grant so
it incentivizes them to merge sius and
it cost $200 a student okay what what
page are you on uh this is just the just
at the bottom here uh the same one yeah
at the the last last little row there
SAU merger we have zeros in
there there
the
yep papich thank you um while I know
this would be terrible policy I swear to
God sometimes I'm tempted to charge a
fee to people who split Asus for the
exact same reason I understand that uh
it's not legislation I'm planning to
propose but given how much duplication
in Services usually results from SAU
splitting you know it's what it is it
was discussed during the um when the seu
merger bill was going through the
process um I've seus haven't really
Consolidated since like the 1960s so
yeah the trend is to for sius to split
up um the other thing to point out um
and this is one of the challenges we
have so this adequacy number we're
pretty comfortable with because adequacy
uses data from one year behind where it
gets a little more challenging for the
the department and for all of you is
forecasting the programs that use
current data so charter school adequacy
we pay in real time this year in which
the student was educ educated we provide
the uh Charter School Grant um same with
education Freedom accounts so it's
that's all happening in real time so the
reasons why we have updated numbers for
you for Charter School uh funding and
EFA funding is because the data is
coming in real time so we're getting
continuous data collection points and
then it's helping us uh forecast our
estimates to be more accurate about the
current year in which we're educating
the child and paying for their education
and then also future fiscal years so
um uh we have a couple different
estimates relative to charter school
funding so so specifically to what Mark
is just talking about so for Charter
Schools we had a payment that we just
made on March 1st to all of the charter
schools so this data is super Super
Fresh you're some of the first people
that are seeing this information because
this is a based on a very recent count
and when we get into the efas same sort
of thing they actually have a payment on
April 1st but they count on March 1st so
they are in the process of counting we
have that count prelimary information in
this packet but it wasn't available to
other people when they were working on
the budget so when you're looking at
Charter Schools and you look at your
packet um so what we have in here is so
we have new Charter we've kind of broken
it down to existing charter schools so
those are the charter schools that are
there that their doors are open that
there's kids in there right now in this
school year and then we have new and
pending charters schools which mean
these schools haven't opened yet some of
them have been approved by the State
Board of Education some of them haven't
been we're kind of in the process of
getting them approved and through that
process and there could be some costs um
or there will be some costs associated
with those schools and we've really
thought it was important to break down
that bucket because the existing schools
it's you know their enrollment number is
probably a much more predictable number
most of the schools are open they have
kids there the new schools the numbers
that we've used are based on their
applications and their Charters but some
of those are maybe more optimistic
numbers than what have you know they
might actually end up opening at and
that's been a historical issue that we
struggled with with Charter Schools so
on the first page well it's actually
page two of your packet that's exactly
what we have we have the breakdown
between existing and new and pending
charter schools so the pending means
just to remind everybody the pending
means we have an application um in place
or or we've received an application um
and we're in the process of working
through the approval process of that to
the State Board of
Education um so if you look on page
three of your packet um we have the
charter schools the existing Charter
Schools um we have the 25 count which
that was the count for the March 1
payment that's right there um that's hot
off the press um and then we have a 26
and a 27 um count that we are estimating
based on historical growth of charter
schools and then also we reviewed
Charter Schools applications were
approved by State Board of Education to
make sure that if we were existing or
projecting growth that we didn't exceed
a charter schools cap so remember when a
charter schools comes to the State Board
of Education they propose an a total
enrollment um and they
appro propose enrollments by grade and
then if the charter school wants to have
more kids than they had originally
approved they actually have to go to the
State Board of Education to request uh
an amendment to their Charter to change
their cap so that is being accounted for
in this this um spreadsheet that you
have here so if you look at it we're
projecting an estimated $70 million for
charter schools for 26 and then $74
million for charter schools for 27 for
just the charter schools that are open
with kids in their doors as of today um
and that includes the virtual Learning
Academy which has two different
functions so virtual Learning Academy is
a virtual charter school that has kids
from all around the state that are
enrolled in traditional Public Schools
accessing courses that are not available
at their local school districts at the
virtual Learning Academy in addition to
kids that are enrolled at the virtual
Learning Academy full-time they'll those
kids will um graduate from the virtual
Learning Academy they can take um and
they'll take all of their classes there
and whatnot so um so in addition to that
the next page on in your packet though
this is this is the number that um is
quite a large number um and we kind of
need to just talk through and make sure
that you're all aware of this so these
are charter schools that we are
projecting will open in the next bym
budget so the first group of them you
can see it's approved that means they
have they've applied to the State Board
of Education the State Board of
Education has approved their application
and they are in various stages of
opening so some of them may be opening
in 26 actually looks like all of the
approv schools that we have here plann
to open in 26 and they'll probably have
kids for 26 and 27 school year and then
we have another group those are the
pending groups those are applications
that we have in various stages of the
application process so some of them
might be going to the State Board
Thursday of this week I'm not sure if we
have one but um to get approved some of
them may be throughout the summer or
throughout the course of the next year
but those are the schools that we know
about they've submitted some sort of
application there's someplace in the
middle of the process um and we
anticipate those schools opening during
the bium but so you can see that the
cost we're projecting relative to these
schools is between 5 and $10 million for
the two years of the bium um and that's
a number that we need to talk about and
kind of see what where are we
comfortable budgeting because it's not
necessar all of these schools may open
and it's not NE they're not necessarily
guaranteed to have this number of kids
on the flip side of though some of these
schools could open with more kids than
originally projected so it did really
kind of the enrollment on them is a lot
harder to predict because they're not
accepting kids right now do we have any
way to
say schools can open um you do as the
legislature we don't as the Department
of Education actually um it's been kind
of it's been put in law that the State
Board of Education cannot deny Charter
School applications based on finances
alone so you would need um other um you
would need to write that into hb2 if you
wanted that expectation of the
department and try to basically set a
cap so that we didn't exceed a
certain uh budgeted amount and one of
the reasons why they're continuing to
open um is because we do have a pretty
large Charter School startup Grant so
the Department of Education in 2019
applied and was successful for a $46
million Grant to open charter schools
and those Grant dollars are used for
preliminary um costs associated with
opening a charter school prior to their
opening um and so um we actually on the
last page of your packet I have um kind
of the status of that Grant but we have
opened a fair number of Charter School
Grants with or charter schools with that
Grant um so the the three primary um use
of that Grant is to open a new Charter
School expand an existing charter school
or replicate an existing Charter School
um we've had some we had some initial
delays on that Grant because of some
legislative decisions and then the grant
did kind of get off what we think is
probably a little slower um than it
would have because of the pandemic but
now we are in the end years of our grant
and we're having a lot of applicants
people are very interested in that Grant
and and leveraging that
opportunity repr wer how many years do
the 46 Mill
um so it was a 5-year Grant initially
with the authority to apply for five
additional one c um one at a time no
cost extensions um we're not sure what
that process looks like with the US
Department of Education currently but
right now we are in the first year of
our no cost extension so up to four
additional years are those extensions of
the existing monies yes the existing use
them over an extended period of time yes
yes representative Murray thank you go
ahead oh I was going to say just the
rest of information that's in your
packet or do you w
to um so on the governor's budget in 26
and 27 you're looking at 66 million 68
million you're saying that you need
between 70 and 74 million yes and you
need an additional
55 million uh for the charter school
program potentially yes so we've got a
gap of around $22 million yes and that's
because the the governor's budget was
based on the agency phase of the budget
which we had prepared if you remember a
year ago before there were any schools
open and so when we've done the counts
throughout the year the number has
substantially increased and then we've
also received a lot of applications this
year there's there's been a lot of
momentum um to open no new Charter
Schools this
year I'll just add um so yeah page two
has the the existing Charter funding and
the new and pending Charter funding and
so those would be the numbers that if if
you accept these numbers they would get
plugged into the Surplus statement or
hb1 and the Surplus statement as far as
how you're funding Charters um just one
thing to add because uh Kaylin and I
were wrestling with what is a good
methodology there's things that our
methodology doesn't include it doesn't
include any charter schools closing down
that does happen we do have a charter
school close about once a year typically
when a charter school closed down it's
usually a slow death where their
enrollment declines enrollment declines
and they hang on for as long as they can
because they want to educate those
students um and then they eventually
close down um there are sometimes
dramatic closures where multiple
students now have to leave the Charter
system and go to a new Charter system or
find a new educational pathway um but
but we don't forecast any charter
schools closing that could happen which
would save the state uh uh money as far
as this line item um the other thing we
don't include is uh uh these pending
Charter Schools we gave them a reduction
in what they estimate they'll forecast
so a lot of them are very ambitious they
want to get as many students as they can
into their new charter school they're
very excited to open um some of them uh
uh open and they don't have those
numbers that they hoped and dreamed for
um so we did give them a reduction in
that in our estimate um some of them
might not just be able to open they
really would like to open but they don't
open so that's areas where this could
be uh overestimating what charter
schools are going to be as far as
funding is concerned but regardless if
this scenario is true and charter
schools are able to open they're able to
have pretty good enrollments um
enrollment Trends hold this would be
again back to the education trust fund
warrant aspect of it this is what we
would have to pay so um there's there's
this methodology is not perfect there's
a lot of assumptions that go in here a
lot of this could happen couldn't happen
we think these are fair numbers that you
should plug into hb1 um given all the
data and assumptions included in this
model um but it might it might come out
cheaper might come out more expensive
might come out
cheaper repres d as charter schools are
increasing public schoool should be
decreasing so is there an offset how
that that's a good point uh so we we we
just include for our district adequacy
uh we just have the standard 1.2%
enrollment decline um which would that's
a historical Trend with Charter Schools
online so uh uh yeah potentially that
1.2 could be light so it could be there
could be higher District enrollment
decline um that's assuming students are
going from the district system to the
Charter system um of course as you'll
see in a lot of the LBA fiscal notes
students could go from the home
education system to a Charter system or
the EFA system to the Charter system so
h a lot of different ways that's a
variable we haven't factored in but
that's a good observation also remember
it's not a Ono one so there's base
adequacy that charter schools get but
and District Public Schools get District
Public Schools do not get an
extraordinary needs grants but all
charter school kids receive an
additional Charter School Grant of it's
about $5,000 per kid for this coming
bium so it it's not necessarily A Ono
one um there could be more costs
associated with the kid going to a
charter school or less depending on
which district they come from but but
the point is that sorry just to the
complexity of the variable you're saying
is absolutely true but we've not
considered that in any model and we
wouldn't really know how to do that uh
uh right now right now thank you thank
you uh chairman wer thank
you when you look at the um grades from
kindergarten through 12 isn't there a
decline from one grade to another in so
the that the population of children is
really decreasing yes so and and we're
really paying about
$10,000 total per Char a student how
much of that money is coming from the
school
itself um just some rough numbers um
just to confirm uh yeah we see we see uh
uh student enrollment declining overall
we see that Trend um there could be
bumps and fluctuations but generally
that's the trend and that's why we
forecast declining enrollment at least
in district schools where most students
are um uh the um uh the $110,000 number
so Charter Schools run their they run
their nonprofit the Quasi nonprofit non
uh public school um it cost them about
$10,000 generally about 85% of it is
state funded so um um so the numbers
around the cost per people of a charter
school yeah because some of it's free
and reduced etc etc uh donations so
donations um they reimburse locally
sometimes you said the state divides 85%
so even though we're given like 5,000
something per per student that's the
base Cost Plus free and reduce plus
special we're actually giving $9,000 for
every charter school kid plus plus the
differentiated Aid and everything like
thank
yes oh yeah you're right you're right
the differential Aid would be on top of
that would make up some of that uh uh uh
variance as well that's correct
represent muray thank you uh so you
saiding the state pays 85% of the
tuition for the charter schools how much
uh what
parameters and how much do you how much
does That Vary around charter schools in
terms of where they're raising their own
monies varies a lot um there because
because there's several charter schools
that have relationships with school
districts so school districts are
subsidizing the charter schools so we
have a charter we have some charter
schools in the state that their average
cost for pupil is around $30,000 per kid
and most of that is tuition dollars
you're receiving from a local school
district and then we have other charter
schools that their amount that they're
receiving is right or spending per stent
is right around that per pupil $9,000
$110,000 amount because they're
receiving this and then some federal
funds from the Department of Education
the title grants that we spoke about
before those go to Charter Schools but
other than that they're not necessarily
doing a lot of local fundraising and and
charter schools are different too when
you're looking at their financial some
of them um are able to bring in Surplus
so they're they're having years where
they have more money coming in than
expenditures going out and so then
eventually at some point they want to
spend that Surplus and uh make change
operations in some sort of way and so
the the numbers can really fluctuate um
in different from districts that's sort
of a quasi nonprofit um in addition to
the some of the grants that they may get
from you know beyond the state do they
do is there a fundraising arm to some of
these Charter Schools most of the
charter schools do quite try to do quite
a bit of fundraising
Doan
Charters all right last in your pocket
for today we have education Freedom
accounts so education Freedom accounts
we've already done a fair number of
presentations in this room about this as
far as the way program worked at the
Department of Education and then I know
that um Kate Beaker was here on Friday
and provided a lot of information to the
committee so the Department of Education
really put some disinformation on there
just to show you how um kind of our
estimates have worked and kind of what
our current projections are so just like
Charter Schools um efas had a count on
March 1st and so we have the newest
enrollment information from them so as
of March 1st they had
5,794 kids at the beginning of the year
or actually last summer when the
Department of Education was doing its
projections we had thought their
projection originally would be 5300 kids
so they had 500 more kids um than we had
originally projected based on their
enrollments that they had last summer um
so the program continues to grow so
we've updated our estimates from our
agency vase budget of of the budget um
to be uh 34 million for 26 which would
give us a enrollment of about 600 more
kids of 6,500 and then 7500 for 27 of 41
million so those are the costs of the
Department's projected under the current
law um the information that you have in
your packet if we just flip through it
real quick cuz most of it's duplicative
to information that you have already
received um so we have the um way the
formula works and I should have
mentioned too this was also in your
Charter School pack packet and me um
explaining how the charter school
formula works we like to distribute that
as many times as possible um we have the
EFA enrollment history so um if you
remember you saw that for regular
adequacy in charter schools it's getting
smaller and smaller for efas now as
we've added more years but you kind of
can see how we've increased the base
amount in adequacy and how that impacts
the EFA program as well as well as
charter schools and that goes for all of
the differentiate differentiated AIDS um
and then oftentimes we get a lot of
requests for what the breakdown of um
the number of free and reduced launch
special education English language
learner kids so that's all in that
historical documentation and then you
can see what are how much we're spending
in total for the education Freedom
account program um the next thing in
your packet is for the March 1 payment
um it has the count um in there um and
all of the information that we have um
and then the last thing in your packet
that we just put there just for your
informational purposes um is the phase
out Grant so um so the phase out Grant
is a grant that is paid to District
Public Schools when a child leaves an
EFA or leaves a public school and takes
it an EFA the very first year that the
kid leaves its Public School receives
100% because adequacy is one year in a
the second year year the child's left
this Public School receives 50% and the
third year this CH the School receives
25% for that child um we calculate that
through fiscal year 26 and that's the
last year that we'll be calculating that
and then that Grant goes away so we kind
of laid out the cohorts here for you to
kind of follow through um because there
we've been asking we've been getting a
lot of questions relative to how of
those cohorts work and when we pay those
last cohorts so the last cohort will get
or it will be in fiscal year 20 six um
but it will be paid through fiscal year
28 um and that information is there and
so the Department's projections for the
phase out grants um are about a million
$1.2 million for fiscal year 26 and $1.2
million for fiscal year
27 and when we calculate it in fiscal
year 26 that will be the last time we
calculate it and so then those budget
estimates will be set for 27 and then
fiscal year 28 when we work on that
budget as well
the pen
Phillips so with the governor's proposal
for expansion of the for children who
are leaving the public school sorry I
lost my mic there um for the Governor's
proposal for um students for expanding
the EFA program for students who leave
the public school there would be no
phase out grant for them moving forward
is that correct
any other
questions so just so I'm clearing that
final chart there the highlighted in
yellow how does it diff distinct from
not highlighted at the very end of each
row so you've got FY 26 with a yellow
highlight then you skip over to the FY
26 at the end adequacy harm is that the
actual total this is the the yellow is
supposed to be U it's our estimates for
phas out for the budget so uh fiscal
year 25 is the actual for fiscal year 25
uh fiscal year 26 is uh uh essentially
that methodology is we take the number
it's just basically 39 students uh left
the district system for the for an EFA
and it red it caused U that fiscal year
impact and so we just added 2% to that
essentially and so if you follow the EFA
formula calculation then gets you to EFA
phase out rant of 1.2 million in fiscal
year 26 so that's all that is is us just
coming up with revised budget estimates
oh I'm sorry I I was I thought you're on
the next one already you're not there
yet you're not there you're not on the
next page yet um one that doesn't have a
header on it page 12 yes yeah so what's
going on between the 1.2 million and the
1.6 million oh so uh the the way phase
out works is that fiscal year 26 we call
call it harm so this is harm when a
student leaves a district goes to an
education Freedom account that District
loses out inadequacy and PHS out needs
to pay them so the total amount of harm
as measured by that that methodology is
1.6 million but we don't pay the
district 1.6 million we pay them 50% of
that which is the
823k in the fiscal year in which the
harm was curred and then we pay them 25%
of the harm done in FIS year 25 okay so
uh you're basically taking that 823k
adding that 43k and you're getting that
1. so that's the pH out it's a little
tricky that La okay yeah right
exactly thank
you and I'm sorry Murray go ahead
um so the governor's budget has the
750,000 so again uh what doe is saying
they need is considerably more than what
the governor is projecting she correct
correct why
so what did the governor use to come up
with 750,000 use the agency the agency's
projections those are our original
projections but because we have new or
better data we've been able to update it
since
then represent hacken Phillips so um I'm
interested in um what the charter I'm
sorry the education Freedom
account
um numbers for 26 and 27 would be if we
were to accept the Assumption of the
governor's expansion of the program do
we have estimates for that so I I
believe Kate Baker gave you guys some
numbers last week um oh for the the
governor's yeah so the governor it is
page two of that document so we think uh
we think if you implement law 512
produced okay the 34.8 million again the
program predict EFA program enrollment
but that 3.4 Million number SE okay um
and then the governor put forward
41.1 million 27 and we're not disputing
that okay so these assume the one-year
public students are migrating yep under
these numbers the governor yeah would
be thank
you represent thank you um I thought I
had understood
um back to that page um the governor has
hold on one second what oh go aheading
up
there want make not be I think he's
asking question want to be
clear on the sheet you gave us it's
44 oh wait I see 41 what you seeing 44
oh all over there yeah so this is this
is current law so we did so the
governor's governor's office projected
um with the additional kids the increase
of 44 million and we believe that's
sufficient our is 41 so 41 sufficient or
44 sufficient so so 41 is sufficient
based on current law and enrollment if
the governor if if if the proposal is to
increase the governor's proposal which
is um access for all public school kids
we believe the 44 is sufficient so the
41 is based on current law 44 is based
on something that something in law that
might change correct and we don't know
where that's going to end up right now
correct thank you thanks
Mickey correct right now it's 350% of
FPL just may yeah go ahead and um I mean
there's there are a lot of proposals out
there we don't know where they're going
to end um part of the governors which I
don't think is in a bill is you have to
be in this public school for a year
before you're eligible
um how do you consider those numbers
when you're making your estimates of
people joining an EFA program but again
we don't know if that's so our estimate
just we just estimated current year the
governor did a proposal and and did
their estimate at 44 and we don't have
any additional information on
that um yeah difficult to estimate um
and and so just always keep in mind as
far as whatever the number you put in
there if the program is more successful
than you envisioned it's going to cost
more uh money so always just be mindful
of
that anybody
else any other comments from yeah just
one thing Mick Mickey and I were talking
about and I think he's already U fiscal
year 25 Charter Schools um so uh Vicky
presented a surplus statement that said
the warrant would be $6 million for
charter schools in fiscal year 25 and
that's on the Surplus statement U Mickey
I've been talking about how much money
is carried over and so that warrants Pro
I'll give Mickey an official more
detailed number but essentially instead
of a $6 million warrant it's likely
going to be more like $3 million so you
got a little saving there found found
you $3 million did not find you did not
find you tens of millions of dollars but
um um just but that's just just want to
get that on record that Mickey will
produce that uh number for you and it's
based on our conversations about how
much money we think is available that
doesn't need to go through the warrant
process okay thank you did you have some
comments you'd like to so I'll just kind
of add on to that talking about the
Surplus statement so the one Mark was
referring to is the one I provided to
everyone on the 19th of February um so
that number there we'll we'll adjust
that number for 25 our Assumption of how
much it's going to be spent uh this year
uh but the department did just present
Charter School numbers EFA numbers EFA
phase out grant numbers that are very
different than what the governor has in
the governor's recommended budget so I
would like to put a another snapshot
together for you but I I will need
guidance from the committee and it
doesn't have to to be today of what the
committee wants to assume for these
programs so you've got numbers the
governor appropriated you have estimates
from the Department it's still the
prerogative of this committee to come up
with your budget estimates for those for
those programs so you're going to love
this could you prepare one a s statement
based
on the Department's
estimates purely and you've already done
the governor's estimates correct that's
essentially what you have now
essentially yeah I mean and and those
the governor's estimates the governor's
Surplus statement won't change
division twos will change when we do a
compar to it so I can build a division
two with the governor's or excuse me the
Department's estimates in there now
let's not call division two yet let's
just call it the education
departments okay for division two or
something of that nature so it doesn't
imply that we've settled on that just we
can start looking at that and understand
that create I can create something that
that shows the impact of carrying these
estimates yep yeah it seems like it's
pretty substantial yeah I I think it
could
be substantial leave at that put tens of
millions of
dollars okay um further questions from
the
committee further comments from yeah go
ahead represent um I I'm wondering in
with part of you know the estimates that
you're putting in um trying to
accommodate what the legislature might
do with regards to some of the bills but
it seems to me that may be you know
whether or not there's a year whether or
not you have to be in school for year
before you're eligible to afas whether
it's going to be 350 whether it's going
to be 400 but that may be above and
beyond what we need to do right now
right now yes but eventually no right so
so let's let's assume House Bill 115
which I believe is the FAA expansion
bill passes I think it's on the floor
this Thursday and does get referred to
finance or whatever um once it becomes
the position of the house whether it's
in the budget or crosses over in a
separate bill as part of the budget
surplus statement pack we would want an
estimate to carry for the cost of that
bill just like any other bill so that
that's we're a little we're a little
ahead of that one but that'll be a
second committee Bill presumably so we
can deal with that
then we all
said anything else well I think the
question is what else do you need from
the Department of Education for our
budget at this point I can't tell you
what else I need does anybody else know
what they might need about 50 m
thanks I I think you've given us all you
can for the moment but that's subject to
change the only thing I'll point out is
um earlier this morning there was some
additional technical corrections to hb2
um uh that language Mickey has that
language um so if you have any questions
about any because you haven't had time
to discuss it but if you see anything
relative to hb2 um there's some changes
with how we do uh special education Aid
forecasting um and uh um syncing up how
we uh pay Charter Schools instead of
paying them off a November first
headcount
um uh we asked them to do an October 1
head count and then we asked them to do
a November 1 head count so we have uh
language that Mickey has that basically
says how about we just do the October 1
headcount and don't bother sending the
November 1 numbers in so these are all
technical issues but as you see anything
uh relative to hp2 any tech technical
agers as you work with Mickey uh feel
free to reach out to us too um and I
think Caitlyn was speaking to that this
morning and indicated that there was I
to say what you just said but that there
was going to be some way to handle the
situation with special cases for for a
particular school that or District that
had yeah that that's another language
that actually is introduced in hb2 so if
you um didn't change that that's the
that's the process about um uh
rectifying data after taxes have been
set um So currently we allow districts
to uh um uh um districts can change
their data after taxes have been set and
it does impact their revenue flows um
we're going to try to restrict that
process and allow them to actually
require them to the State Board to
change their data after taxes have been
set so we're trying to put more controls
over that process that's an H we have a
lot of little tiny little data
processing stuff in hb2 which is can get
technical so if you do have questions
about that definitely reach out um okay
but was that related to the comments you
just made about the two those are
different ones so could you
differentiate those two so do you have
the proposal from this morning still um
so the first one is District adequacy so
District adequacy um we get that the
summer is about to end when the summer
ends districts are going to send in
their eii why then we spend all summer
making sure um uh there's no conflicting
student data so the school year is about
to end yeah the school year is about to
end not the summer sorry uh uh uh and as
the before the summer ends um we're
working with the school districts to
make sure that um they've accurately
accounted for all their students and So
eventually get to the point where the
data is settled and then we start paying
September 1st adequacy based on that
data that we've spent all summer vetting
um then on October 1st we vet the data
just a little bit more and then we end
up paying uh um uh don't pay adequacy
but then we give Dr our adequacy
estimates in October
1st then Dr sets taxes off that sometime
between October 1st and April they might
go oh we we missed a student here or
missed a student there we're trying to
stop that process and say if you do make
a change to any of your student
enrollment data after October 1st
there's going to be a process where you
have to petition the state board and
request that we change it instead of
just asking us re the estimates I want
to clarify it's not for the school year
they're currently in it's for the school
year that is already closed they're not
adding any more additional kids for that
school year that they had the
opportunity to count for that school
year so it's not like it's a kid that
came and went during this existing
school year and that's a little bit of
the confusion and people oftentimes get
confused with this and like oh yeah you
were updating it throughout the year and
like no no no this has nothing to do
with this this is after taxes set the
numberers set we've done federal
reporting on that number we've set cost
per pupil on that number we've done a
whole bunch of things it shouldn't be
changing it should just Frozen yeah just
as a commentary and I've talked to
Chairman Earth about this whenever we do
data collection I always say we're only
as good as our weakest link and so if
there's an SAU that's dragging dragging
their feet to get data to us um um that
slows down the whole process and so we
have phone calls where're well you're
the last seu in the state we need the
data you need to get it in so we can do
adequacy and so this process would just
say you're the last seu in the state
we're moving on you can go to the state
board if you need if you need to move
forward so it just adds a little bit uh
we think adds a little more control to
the process so the other ones on so on
your um spreadsheet from this morning
that house bill to so item number five
is one of the technical Corrections Mark
mentioned relative to State special
education Aid so right now for State
special education Aid We're actually
using an estimated cost per pupil rather
than the actual cost per pupil the
estimated cost per pupil is estimated
using a a pretty technical calculation
Mark does it with school district
budgets and some of their actual
expenditures and we thought it would be
it's only used the only reason we're
doing this estimate is for this area
specifically it's not like we're using
in other areas of the department and we
really felt that for State special
education Aid it should use the actual
actual cost per pupil rather than an
estimated cost per
pupil yeah go ahead um and special ed is
done in real time no special education
is what paid one year as in a r one year
so it is still the one year in events so
I guess that would have been um you
actually do know the cost there isn't
any so so yeah what the cost is and what
would happen is they would send out the
invoices in June so as the as the year
would end they would say based on 3.5x
the cost per pup that we published in
January so you would know the number 6
months earlier 3.5x the number that was
known been known for a while now um go
ahead and submit your invoices um well
not they don't do in June I think it's
May but basically a number that would
been recorded by the department um in
around December and January um in the
springtime they're saying submit your
voices uh uh for special education Aid
um so this just mechanically but
currently what we're doing is in April I
make an estimate and I give it to the
Bureau of education and then they send
out that estimate so it would be quicker
instead of me doing an estimate in April
based on budgets um uh it would just be
it would just be the actual number so
yeah it seemed if it is a year behind as
you saying you do you have the number
yep so and then the last one is number
13 so that willly is with Charter School
we just it feels kind of silly that
they're doing an additional account for
us in November when they've done on
October on October 1st well they've
really done it like October 15th but
based of as of October 1st it's
unnecessary work for both the department
and the charter schools to go through to
get to a number that is pretty much the
same as on October 1st and us to make
that payment for to the charter schools
so we thought would just help with
efficiencies on
everybody I hope so
everybody get all
that right now when I get home maybe
not we'll have them back if we need to
but hopefully we won't need to here and
available other uh anything else one go
ahead um around special ed we were
talking just a little bit um it was
suggested at some point and you had
reminded me having someone who sort of
boots on the ground around special ed
come in and is it too late to have that
to have a superintendent or someone who
works with special ed to have walk us
through what actually happens in the
school district when a special ed
student comes in is there still time to
have someone come in to do that or do
you think it's not necessary I guess I'd
refer that to Mr Lander so
sometime maybe next week maybe the week
after uh we're going to get bills
referred to us presumably on Thursday
one being House Bill 773 which is
related to the cadid program so perhaps
when we schedule a work session on that
bill I'll invite the department to come
in like I always do and perhaps they can
see if there's administrator that makes
sense to to bring in for for that to
sure that great does that make
sense yeah we do several many
several remind
Wednesday e
else get duplica we don't need
toar so thank you all for coming Kaitlyn
and your crew um to see you again
appreciate it
thank you very
much I hope you get paid
well you can look it
up okay so there anything else Mr so um
if we're done for today I think that's
we had a productive day so Friday we
have a work session scheduled at 10: uh
I'm going to come in with some tracking
sheets just to kind of compile
everything you've kind of heard to this
point and try to get it all in front of
you um perhaps some amendments easy ones
like we've talked about some things in
house bill to um perhaps some sections
that could just be deleted because they
have other bills up I'm going to try to
come up with a plan the next couple days
and then I'll kick it to you guys by
Thursday so you know what we're doing
Friday but um if you have any questions
between now and then just feel free to
reach out to me great anything
else okay do it being 211 I will uh call
the end of the division 2 Finance
meeting
y
e
e for